should actually end with the word with
the word with the with the words
paragraph one d one parenthesis small d
right now it goes on to say or detained
for a period of not more than 72 hours
that I don't know where that came from
but it shouldn't be there so that that
should be eliminated
um
a one uh sort of minor uh but
nonetheless this is a substantive change
to some extent is in
um that same section three
uh let's see three
um B
no I'm sorry 3C which I might copy is
Page four of the bill you'll see where
it says and I'm just I'm quoting your
failure of a person to abide by previous
bail conditions if there is probable
cause to believe that while on release
pending resolution of a previous offense
the person committed a felony Class A
misdemeanor or driving or operating
while impaired was released on bail and
thereafter was arrested
I changed that from was arrested for
to commit it because this is an issue
that it came up in when I was on the
spirit court for that there used to be a
a condition of of probation that you
shall remain arrest free
well the problem with that is if if
somebody gets arrested and there's no
valid basis for the arrest that can't be
a basis for violating their probation
and so that that that same language kind
of creeped into this so that the real
the real thing is you should have
committed an offense not just been
arrested for it so that's why a change
made that change and then the only other
changes that I've made
um which you'll see is the uh later on
in the in sections uh 10 10 and of the
bill uh there's reference to this to the
district court and since the district
court is now the Circuit Court I made
that change so I guess what I'd like to
do is very briefly to just go through
um
the major changes that um this bill
would would accomplish first of all it
provides for very serious offenses which
are listed it provides that
um if a court fines by a clear and
convincing evidence standard
um
uh that the person is dangerous then the
court must order the person detained now
some I I remember I talked to a
representative and maybe you're going to
hear from representatives of the law
enforcement community
who thought that it would be better to
have a rebuttable presumption that there
be detention in that circumstance
I have uh respect with respect to them I
think that would go too far to say that
even if a person does not have any kind
of a criminal record
um if they're arrested for a really
serious offense aggravated felonious
sexual assault but let's assume they
have no record
that the court that it would be
appropriate for for there to be a
rebuttable presumption that they'll be
detained it seems to me that just goes
too far
um if you're depriving somebody of their
of their Liberty and it seems to me that
that
um I would say Others May differ but I
would say at a minimum there should be
clear and convincing evidence that the
uh that the person is dangerous before
in this particular case not just because
of the crime they're charged with in
order for them to be uh to be held
without bail
in subsection uh 592 uh the 597 colon 2
3B
which deals with with less serious but
still serious offenses
um you'll you'll notice that there there
is not a requirement of detention but
the judge has discretion to detain but
again it only is if there's a finding of
clear and convincing evidence uh that
the person is a danger
um with regard to um
[Music]
risk of failure to to appear again the
standard is clear and convincing
evidence so the only I think what you'll
see is the only places in this bill
where I have employed the rebuttable
presumption
is in circumstances where the person has
a prior history of committing offenses
there it seems to me it does make sense
uh to to apply a reputable presumption
and I should say here one of the one of
the arguments that was made by the by
some people in law enforcement Community
was well under federal law there they do
use a rebuttable presumption for serious
offenses even if there's even if the
person uh does not have a prior history
of other offenses the court can say that
the that uh because of the nature of the
offense there's a rebuttable presumption
and the defendant has to has to rebut
that again as I said for the reason I
said bill before I don't think that
that's appropriate in circumstances
where a person does not have a prior
history but where they do and you'll see
that there's a in section
597-23p3 there's a rebuttable
presumption of a risk of failure to
appear if the person has three prior
non-appearances in a five-year period or
two prior non-appearances in uh in the
present case
for those circumstances the bill has a
lower standard of proof the court has to
find only by a preponderance of of the
evidence
[Music]
subsection C of
59723c of the bill that's a very
important provision because one of the
things we heard last year was there was
there was a real concern about persons
who have committed just repeat offensive
continually commit repeat offenses and
it can be you know it may not be a
violent offense it may be something like
like theft but if it happens again and
again and again uh the uh the the court
the court should be able to say that
look this this person is a danger in the
sense that if we keep releasing and
they're going to keep committing
offenses and so subsection C would allow
if there are if there's probable cause
to believe that a person committed two
prior offenses a while out on bail than
the court has the authority to set to
make that determination
uh
the
you'll also notice in in RSI I think
again this is an important provision the
an RSA 5 and I propose RSA 597 to Roman
numeral four
the bill provides that the Rules of
Evidence don't apply in bail hearings
that's uh that's uh traditionally been
the the way the law is operated but the
rule but the statute specifically
provides that whatever evidence the
court considers has to be reliable so
the court you know as an example the
court might be able to consider hearsay
evidence in a particular case but only
if it's reliable evidence if the court
has some question about is this evidence
reliable or is it just you know is this
not worth very much then the court
doesn't have to consider it
um
so that I'm and I'm gonna I'm happy to
take any questions on on any of the
points I just uh talked about
um
I now want to turn to what is probably
the most touchy issue about this bill
and that is the elimination of bail
Commissioners let me say at the outset
that I have I have nothing against fail
Commissioners I you know I don't I don't
know that I know any bail Commissioners
personally although maybe there are some
people who have worked in the court
system and are bail Commissioners and I
just didn't know that but
um uh I've heard good things about many
bail Commissioners I've also heard you
know some things that that some bail
Commissioners do not do a particularly
good job but my point is not to uh you
know is not to sort of rank on bail
Commissioners my basic point is this is
simply this
it seems to me
that
if you're going to have the authority
to take away some someone's Liberty
the person who does that ought to be a
judge
I think that's uh you know who was who
has gone through the Constitutional
process of being nominated by the
governor confirmed by the council and
appointed by the governor to make those
those kind of decisions
and I think you know I I understand that
there's that there may be sort of a
sympathy for lack of a better term
element that uh we you know we don't we
don't want to sort of uh
say to bail Commissioners uh you know
sorry but we've we've kind of turned
over a new Leaf I I have to say when I
was in the court system we went through
the same thing uh when Joe Neto was the
Chief Justice of the Superior Court this
Supply goes back quite a while to the uh
to uh
uh the late 1990s with court reporters
that it just made more more sense to do
away with to eliminate the court
reporter position and and replace it
with court monitors and that was a very
tough decision because there were court
reporters who were really good and we
liked them a lot and we you know to say
that that your position has kind of
outlifted it lived its usefulness is a
tough thing to do I understand that
um but I do think in terms of what is
what is best for the system
it makes more sense to have professional
uh lawyer-trained judges who have gone
through the the vetting process of of
being appointed as judges to be deciding
questions of taking away somebody's
Liberty I think that I think that that
makes a you know makes eminent sense and
that's the basic reason uh for my uh
proposing uh to eliminate the pale
Commissioners and and and
appoint
additional Circuit Court judges I know
you're going to hear from Mr head from
the judicial branch and I want to
emphasize that
the band the judicial branch has
concerns which I think are entirely
legitimate about timing of any of this
whether you agree with my bill I know
there's a bill by representative
shirtleff who I greatly respect uh that
would instead of replacing bail
Commissioners with judges would replace
them with magistrates
I frankly prefer the judge that's why
it's in this my my bill but you know
that's uh I don't I certainly don't say
that that he's just flat wrong with the
magistrates
but what I want what I would emphasize
is I think you're going to hear from Mr
head that the judicial branch is
concerned about the timing of this how
quickly can it be done what resources
will they need to do this and I you know
those are all entirely legitimate
concerns uh and I hope and he's got a
lot more current information on that
than I do so I would you know I hope
you'll you'll give careful consideration
to what he has to say and if this you
know it may be as an example just as
something for you to consider maybe you
decide that yes the substantive
provisions of the bail reform we should
do but we shouldn't make the change on
bail Commissioners for a period of time
uh so that this can be so that this can
uh that the judicial branch will have
time to adopt
um and May and maybe you'll say we
should we shouldn't do any of this right
now we to give the judicial branch time
to adopt I
um I you know you that's a decision for
this committee to make uh and I
certainly respect whatever your decision
may be in that that's really all I I
have to say I'm happy to answer
questions
thank you for your testimony uh
representative I I have a first question
is with regards to replacing the um
the bail commercials were judges do you
see the judges having the bandwidth to
be able to pick up that kind of a load
that is currently being carried by the
number of bail Commissioners we have
I do I mean one of the things that I
think and this is probably not for this
committee but one of the things that I
think Mr head will tell you and it's
it's absolutely correct is the judicial
branch in fact before I started to
believe that it's over three years since
I left but before I left we the judicial
branch decided to to um
uh have a new weighted case study done
which was not was which was started I
think before I left but it was not
completed until very recently because of
covert and some other things
that study shows that the Circuit Court
in particular needs you know a
significant increase in in judges
and I don't have any doubt that they do
need an increase in judges so
um
and that's before this bill so I you
know do they
if if we were to impose this bill now
without giving them any additional
resources the answer is no they wouldn't
be able to do it
um so I think they do need additional
resources my understanding from speaking
with Chief Justice McDonald and this was
a a while ago and I should say this was
not you know
I I don't I don't mean to sort of pin
him down to this because we were just
sort of talking informally but is my
from my discussion with him my
understanding was that that the judicial
branch was going to be asking for seven
additional Circuit Court judges without
this considering this bill and that if
you considered this bill that would
require one and a half to two additional
Circuit Court judges and I have no
reason to doubt that that's correct
maybe it's you know maybe maybe they
have revised their thinking a little bit
on that even you know even more I don't
I don't know but but the short short
answer to your question is without
additional resources no they wouldn't be
able to do it
representative Newman
oh with what you just said about the uh
the requirements on the court uh would
require one and a half or two judges
does that take into consideration that
the bail Commissioners are available 24
hours
non-business hours all the non-business
hours right
um that seems like a small number to me
but I'm not a judge or a lawyer yeah you
know well I mean a couple of things to
to think about there oh that you know
because actually that raises a very very
important Point here
as you read this as you read this bill
understand that this the one of the uh
the
language in
uh let me let me just find it yeah um
the language in section four on on page
two says that um
for example uh all persons direct all
persons arrested with or without a
warrant for a criminal essential for
driving Etc and not released upon a
summons to appear
so that the you know what what
this bill contemplates candidly and
although the judicial branch would be
able to I suppose the judicial branch
would be able to if they wanted to have
night court but but my suspicion is they
probably would would choose not to do
that and so what basically what what the
uh what would would happen is the person
would if the person was arrested for a
serious enough offense that the officer
believed the person could not be
released on the summons uh you know and
that there needed to be some bail they
would end up being held until the next
more until the next morning when they
could be brought before the court which
this bill requires that they be brought
before the court within 24 hours on the
other hand if it was if the officer
decided that this was not really a
serious enough offense to require the
person to be held they could
um they could take the person to the
police station for purposes of
processing but then release them on a
sum
and that would be up to the you know
that would be up to the to the officer
and just as a follow-up so they're
required to be to see the court within
24 hours right so now we have the
situation where it's uh an event where
the police think he's going to be held
but now it's midnight on Friday
how does that square with 24 hours and
the possibility that there's not a
availability of a court appearance until
perhaps the following Tuesday right that
well there this I this does accept
weekends and holidays so you're I mean
you're right there could be there could
be a situation where a person would be
held until until uh Monday morning
that's this that's true I mean
thank you
other questions
representative Jameson
thank you for taking my question
uh
I'm going back to when I was in criminal
justice when I was in college and my
understanding is the Justice of the
Peace
is the person that is a bill
commissioner and that justice of the
peace is appointed by the circuit court
judge War by the superior court judge to
commission bails
um is that still how it works yeah no
that's that's right it is
and as a follow-up
thank you Mr chairman uh as a follow-up
to that
um if a circuit court or Superior Court
Justice finds that that bill
commissioner is not doing his job in an
acceptable manner to the court is there
a way to replace them very quickly
I don't know about very quickly but
there are I mean if somebody is not
doing their job this short the circuit I
mean the the court you know the court
can could take action to uh to remove
someone yes
thank you Mr chairman for the follow-up
uh and one last question for you um Mr
representative is
um that a bill I'm sorry a justice of
the peace is vetted by the Secretary of
State the governor and council is that
still correct
um
yeah in a manner of speaking yes that's
true that's certainly not in any way the
same level of vetting that occurs with a
with a judge
representative Pratt
okay I'm looking at page four
line 25 and 26.
it says three more times within the past
five years
that's going to uh driving in pay it our
other felonies the class A misdemeanors
I'm sorry I'm having trouble here so the
question is uh on line 25 three or more
times 25 and 26 and Page four
okay within the last five years
or I failed to appear twice in a present
case so we're giving them three times
before we uh actually incarcerate them
well we're giving them we're giving
we're giving three times before there
would be a rebuttable presumption
and I I would say the the person
whatever
whenever a person appears before the
court the court obvious you know is
gonna will consider the issue of bail I
think this really is is addressing the
situations where a rebuttable
presumption would arise so that it would
be the it would be the defendant's
obligation to rebut the presumption
so to clarify that that just means the
burden on the defendant is raised after
the third offense to to
um to get bail right in other words the
state can come in in that situation and
and prove the state has to prove that
there were the three you know the three
essentially but once the state proves
the the three offenses let's say the
state can sit down basically and say you
know your honor based on this we think
you should hold it and send it now it's
the defendant he may offer evidence if
he or she wants to but doesn't have to
and then the judge will decide whether
the presumption has been rebutted
okay thank you representative Reed
so it's my understanding that bail
Commissioners already work under the
direction of a judge and they have
guidelines to follow as how to charge
um bail and when to hold somebody
um they there are many more bail
Commissioners than circuit judges so my
concern is that two one it's going to be
so much more expensive on the taxpayers
to replace Commissioners with circuit
judges or magistrates and
um
the defendant and the police are going
to have to wait so much longer for any
kind of service and if it is it's most
likely going to be by phone whereas
Commissioners show up in person correct
I believe that they do show up in person
yes and you know as far as the I I you
know I
ask anybody for anybody who knows I'm
I'm certainly someone who who is very
much in favor of the idea of keeping
government spending and government
itself small but it does seem to me this
is sort of a fundamental
role of government deciding whether
somebody should be released or stayed in
jail and there is you know there have
been some issues with bail Commissioners
as I say I think I think that there are
some bail Commissioners are very good
there are others that are not so good
and um
I think having a more professional uh
role uh in making that determination
would be a good thing
um and
do you have any data on on
cases that might have been mishandled by
Commissioners is it
one in a hundred interactions one in ten
do you have any data I don't have that
data and I don't know whether the
whether Mr had or someone from the
judicial branch would have that but that
but you know you should certainly ask
them that question
thank you for your testimony this
morning thank you very much
this time the clerk recognize excuse me
the chair recognizes uh Richard head
from the judicial branch
good morning Mr chairman good morning
members of the committee my name is
Richard head I'm the government Affairs
coordinator for the judicial branch
to start we have no position on the
policy of this bill there are at least
my count I believe seven bail reform
bills that are that are out there
between the house and the Senate
versions I did want to briefly talk
about and I appreciate representative
Lynn's comments relative to the
resources and the timing as it impacts
the Circuit Court
a couple things just to recognize with
regard to Circuit Court
um as as representative Lynn mentioned
we've recently undertaken a waited time
case study analysis and that shows a
significant shortage of shortage of both
judges and and I want to emphasize staff
because at the end of the day anything a
judge receives or does is ultimately
getting passed through someone in the
clerk's office and there is also a
significant both
shortage of clerks even at full capacity
but we like everybody else in the
country is experiencing the inability to
bring in enough people to fill all those
slots that we currently have
just some numbers and I apologize for
throwing out some numbers
criminal cases filed in the Circuit
Court alone we're talking roughly on an
annual basis between 60 and 80 000 cases
it's a lot of cases that get pushed
through the Circuit Court last session
you also authorized and approved the
repeal of what was called felonies first
and felonies first was implemented in I
think 2015 in that
changed the process that had existed and
put all felonies felonies would
originate in Superior Court so those
would not be initiated through the
Circuit Court
the repeal of felonies first means that
all of those felonies that are currently
starting in this in the Superior Court
will now begin in the circuit court that
adds roughly another nine to ten
thousand cases that are coming into the
Circuit Court which is already
experiencing some severe
shortages both in terms of Staff in in
judicial resources
if we take for example in representative
Lynn's Bill page 3 line 19 which is the
list of crimes and this is a list that's
that's in a number of the of the bills
that you'll see both in the Senate and
House side
if you take just that list of of crimes
we roughly estimate and if these are all
estimates based on sort of past
experience that will result without
regard to Bringing felonies first into
the circuit court so pretending felonies
first still exist about 2500 new bail
hearings before a judge
not currently in front of the judge if
you sort of estimate
again rough number is not saying this is
a per case let's say they're very
efficient very quick six minutes per
hearing
2500 hearings that has to incorporate
900 000 minutes into the system
and it's a system that is full so my
only my only message is
bail reform and and what you're talking
with regard to these bills also has to
be considered against how those get
absorbed into the system ultimately
and and our request isn't with regard to
the policy I understand and appreciate
that a bill probably will come out of
the house of some sort
um
what I'm asking is and and next week I'm
just going to reference a bill I know
it's not the bill in front of you today
House Bill 46 is a bill that would
authorize magistrates
it does seem to make sense to take some
time with representative Lynn's bill and
the magistrate bill because they both
relate very well with each other because
if you take the rest of Representative
Lynn's bill it essentially says not only
those 2500 new hearings that are going
to come in under that list on page three
but all of all the ones that the bail
Commissioners are currently addressing
in the first instance would also flow
into the superior into the Circuit Court
and that is
um that is a struggle if that's what we
have to do we'll do it and anytime you
put something that has tight deadlines
mandatory deadlines which you start to
talk about when you're in the criminal
world you start to think okay what does
not get done what does not get hurt
because you have a set number of hours
in the day that hearings can be held
that pushes other things down the road
the things that don't have those type of
constitutional or statutory deadlines
and we're trying to avoid that but if we
had to absorb it we would and we would
figure out a way of doing it
the repeal of felonies first
in terms of the management just of the
administration of that between now and
January 1 when that becomes effective we
have staff that are are working on this
continuously it is a very complicated
process from a court administration side
of things and so just that repeal of
felonies first has absorbed a great deal
of time and capacity within the
administrative staff of of the court
system
if we were to add on top of that
putting in a new magistrate system
putting in X number of additional
hearings into the system it is a lot to
absorb
and we we just ask about uh ask you to
consider that kind of absorption of
additional uh caseload you'll hear in
when the when the Chief Justice
ultimately is talking about the budget
proposal that he wants to present he
does try to address these shortfalls
through the budget through staff through
judges and you'll hear about that
weighted case study
um
but it is a lot to take in so our
overall ask is
that at least some of these bills and I
would say specifically this bill and
next week I would do the same on the
magistrate Bill ask that either they'd
be retained or brought together as a
study so that this can be done somewhat
thoughtfully that we have a true sort of
financial evaluation get some input from
the bail from the bail Commissioners get
some data from the bail Commissioners
and have a more
substantive conversation that I think
you can have in the context of these
hearings so our ask is is that this bill
and again I'll ask you next week and
I've spoken with with the prime sponsors
of both those bills
um that they'd be at least retained if
not converted into a study
um I know you have a lot to do I will um
in my comments there and be happy to
answer any questions
thank you for your testimony and taking
our questions
um so basically what the court is saying
is would you please let us Implement
what you told us to do last year before
you tell us to do something else
something like that
we're working on it thank you
representative selig
thank you Mr chair I have a two-part
question
um just wondering right now do the
courts have enough physical space for
all the hearings that they need to have
without adding additional delays
um so thank you for the question it's a
great question so
offhand I don't know the answer
certainly some courts that is an issue
Rochester for example is a Court Circuit
Court and I'm talking circuit courts in
this answer is a circuit court that is
actually divided so that some of the
Circuit Court matters have to be heard
in the spirit court building different
building actually a different town than
in Rochester so there are some space
issues we're trying to address Rochester
last year there was money put in for
engineering study this year there's
money in the proposed in the budget to
build a new courthouse for the Rochester
that's one we have a number of
courthouses where there are some
capacity issues mask follow-up Mr
um thank you for the follow-up um if we
were to implement this bill in some
capacity with some amendments
um how many Circuit Court judges and
staff do you think you would actually
need to add in order to cover the
increased caseload
um so thank you so uh the bill
um uh specifically uh says three judges
um
so we have more than three courthouses
if we looked just at the busiest
courthouses for criminal filings we're
talking as you would expect Southern
Tier
the busiest I think our Nashua
Manchester Concord Rochester and I would
add Keen into that
um so you're talking at least those
courthouses probably need a judge but
and this is
to be very clear on top of sort of
existing loads so when the chief is
presenting his budget he's talking
current sort of loads
um and then when we get into staff I'm
talking about staff
you know we would be talking about
a great deal of work and I don't want to
minimize this the work that is done by
the bail Commissioners there's a great
deal of paperwork time spent by bail
Commissioners that would be moved into
the clerk court staff in that paperwork
the the work that that goes along with
deciding bail that the judges are doing
would get incorporated into court staff
again
while all ports would be impacted again
the courts with the largest criminal
load would be impacted more
um so I think you that's that's where
most of the resources would would need
to be focused but throughout the system
there would be resource limitations to
answer your question specifically is it
two staff three and don't actually have
a good sense of that yet and part of of
the goal of looking to either study or
retain is to have one sense of what is
going to pass so we know sort of what
we're dealing with or we're dealing with
the list of crimes or are we dealing
with all crimes
um and and that sort of information Gap
is is just hard to then put some data
together
representative Newman
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
um and when you are gathering your
statistics your stuff and I'm trying to
think about due process it seems like
the 24 I I believe they said that the 75
hours 72 hours in the bill that we have
now was changed to 24 hours so it seems
like that's workable on it on weekdays
on the weekends not so much
so when you were collecting data did you
all right would you consider are you
considering a systems if you're going to
take the bail Commissioners away
that whether it's a magistrate or a
judge that replaces the bail
Commissioners that there would be the
same access to due process that people
have now with the bail Commissioners so
thank you for the question with
um when we're contemplating magistrates
and you heard a lot about from me
magistrates last session in the context
of the bail reforms and and support for
that we were
contemplating it would be available 24
hours a day seven days a week we were
contemplating they would not be in
person events that they would be trans
they would become remote events
um but those in that context we kind of
laid 24 7 with regard to judges the
answer would be court hours uh five days
a week
yeah I had trouble turning the mic on
so so the judges I just wanted a
clarification the judges would be would
be quarter hours and magistrates would
be 24 hours a day and possibly all
telephone some of it telephonic
it's a great Echo chamber you have here
I couldn't quite catch the end of it
the with the judges it would be
considered court hours and with the
magistrates you took into consideration
in your calculations that it would be 24
hours a day but potentially telephonic
would be mixed in with that is that
correct
yes I think that that's right thank you
the and and again with
we did yeah so with the judges I I think
just in terms of capacity they do just
to be clear
there are things that judges are doing
overnight currently so they're warrants
that are being issued by judges their
number of of things that do happen
overnight that judges are currently
doing
um some dcyf um
petitions and those are happening but we
are not at least currently contemplating
with regard to bail that that would be
nighttimes weekends holidays for the
judges thank you
yeah
representative Jim
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh my recollection
from the 1990s when I commissioned bills
out of Hampton district court for
justice Frazier was we got a packet from
the judicial branch that gave us
guidelines on commissioning our bills
could you make that packet available to
the committee the the the
materials that go to bail Commissioners
yes I can I can ask and
um as a second part to that question
um could you if if you don't explain it
now could you in some sort of a
narrative how the requirements
of 597 colon 18a relative to educational
requirements for a bail commissioner are
being implemented by the judicial branch
uh and again I apologize it's hard to
hear yeah that's fine the educational
requirements for the bail commissioner
how the the judicial branch is uh is
actually implementing that statute
currently
I really appreciate it thank you sure
um I'm happy to include that and I'll
check on the on the bail commissioner
materials but I'll be happy to send a
reply
thank you for your time and answering
our questions this morning thank you at
this time the chair recognizes Melissa
Davis
thank you very much good morning my name
is Melissa Davis I'm currently the
director of the criminal Practice Clinic
and an assistant professor at UNH School
of Law prior to joining the law school
as a public defender for 15 years as
director of the criminal Practice Clinic
at the law school a supervised students
representing clients in misdemeanor and
low-level felony offenses so for
essentially the past 18 years I have
represented defendants charged in
criminal cases in New Hampshire state
courts I think what's important to
recognize initially is that this bill
primarily affects people who I believe
you know will be determined not
dangerous and not a Flight Risk
by a judge maybe the next morning maybe
four days later if it's a holiday
weekend in these circumstances these
people you know obviously maybe innocent
of the crime that they are charged with
also they may not uh in the end even if
they are convicted of the charge end up
serving any jail time for these charges
these are people who
um is I understand representative Lynn's
testimony this morning essentially the
process will be that they are arrested
it has been the police officer's
determination whether or not to release
them on the summons the police officer
in that circumstances then therefore
sort of taking the position of the bail
commissioner currently holds that police
officer is obviously involved in the
investigation of the case involved in
the decision to bring the charges May
themselves be a victim of the elect the
charges themselves depending in
resisting arrest cases and things like
that they will then be the person
determining whether or not to issue a
summons or hold someone overnight
presumably or possibly up to four days
with the holiday weekend these kinds of
delays cause substantial effects on
these individuals and I just wanted to
share a couple of instances many of my
clients are parents so many of them are
single parents you even if they are not
single parents their spouse hat also
works and so the issue becomes if they
are held for any amount of time and have
to wait for a judge to see them the next
morning they're missing work not only
are they missing work if they're if they
have a partner who is available who then
has to watch the kids that day their
partner is missing work putting both
their jobs in Jeopardy therefore putting
their housing in Jeopardy and causing a
substantial Interruption to this
family's life again these are people who
would be you know likely released as not
dangerous to the community who would
likely be released as not flight risks
and who in the end are not going to
likely serve jail time at all on these
types of offenses
the other you know another type of
population that you're going to be
hitting are people with substance use
and mental health issues
specifically for people with substance
use and mental health issues one day in
jail
is a traumatic event it can cause
relapse it can cause trauma for them
that has been something that they will
have to deal with for a significant
amount of time afterwards these are
people who may be making it barely
making it but they are making it with
the Assistance or the services provided
in the community when they are
incarcerated for any amount of time
those services are interrupted and it's
very difficult oftentimes to get them
back in place
specifically for people with substance
use issues many of them as we know are
dealing with opioid addiction that is
the best treatment for that type of
addiction is medicated assistance
treatment but medicated assistive
treatment requires medication every
single day medication that the jail is
not going to provide to every single
person who says hi I'm on medicated
assisted treatment I need my dose this
morning because they don't have a
prescription they don't have
verification this person's actually on
the medication and they may not have the
resources to provide it means this
person misses their dose they then go
into a type of
withdrawal which is very painful and
again risks relapse it the same applies
for people on Mental Health medications
many of these people must take
medications at the same time every day
most people are not carrying their
medications around with them so when
they are held even overnight or
especially for longer periods of time
the jails are not
able to prescribe medications quickly
these people will be missing their
medications they risk then
um they then risk uh you know having
effects of those medications the with
the withdrawal of those medications but
also not having those medications which
contribute significantly to other things
in their life being disrupted finally I
will point out the number of unhoused
people who may have a bed at a shelter
if they miss one night at that shelter
they lose their bed they then have to go
back on the waiting list all over again
to get a bed so these even one night in
jail is significant for these
individuals in these situations
on top of that
um these hearings they may be presented
with plea offers they are unrepresented
at these hearings they do not have
lawyers they are rep they're offered the
opportunity to get out of jail these are
people who may be innocent these are
people who may have defenses these are
people who
may have you know there may be issues
with their case that need to be
litigated and their Prime concern as
with all of my clients is I need to get
out of jail and they may be taking
offers and pleading guilty to things
that they should not be taking on as
convictions without the advice of
counsel this is especially concerning
what's concerning in a lot of areas it's
the the consequences of that are very
concerning with motor vehicle offenses
especially considering the habitual
offender law they may be pleading to
Major motor vehicle offenses not knowing
the consequences of that and then have
to deal with the DMV afterwards as a
result because they wanted to get out of
jail
um
sorry just one more Point here I think
what's important to notice this also
includes Class B misdemeanors people who
would not serve jail time even even as a
possible convict even as a possible
sentence in these matters and so overall
I think
um I would urge this this committee to
consider a possible damage of adding
additional time in jail for people who
otherwise would not be sitting in jail
overnight thank you for your time
thank you for your testimony this
morning
um I just have a couple of questions so
at the outset of your testimony you said
that the um they were likely many of
them were likely not guilty likely would
not serve time likely would end up not
being determined to be a danger or
Flight Risk
and we you went on about the possible
effects on these defendants in
in I think a major duty to this
committee is to make sure that there's a
balance between the the victims and and
defendants but I didn't hear you mention
the victims I'm looking at the list of
crimes and these are all very serious
crimes that have victims um
with domestic violence
kidnapping stalking trafficking in
persons felonious use firearms in in
order to get there there's already been
a determination that probable cause
exists to make the arrest so
in layman's terms it's more likely than
not that they committed the offense so
how is it that you you see us balancing
that with the rights of the victims who
also are missing work or possibly dead
in some of these cases sure and I think
that section is somewhat different than
the section that that specifically
requires that everyone be held until
they can be heard by a judge in this
matter which is
um
you know the section that says
right all persons arrested for a
criminal offense including DWI are not
released unless released a part of
summit so that's all crimes which
section you specifically point to I'm
looking at
paragraph
is
it is
597 too
uh the bottom line 29 through 31.
in in regards to the list of crimes that
are then you know sort of determination
about whether or not there is a danger
to the community in that situation these
things are already happening
um you know bail Commissioners are
already and you know I'm not here to
speak about the bail Commissioners but
they're all ready to you know looking at
the nature of the offenses and
determining whether or not someone is a
danger to the community based on the
allegations that are made in those
circumstances judges in those situations
are also when bail motions are file
taking into account those situations I
will say that without a fact
determination of what is the exact type
of conduct that is being charged in a
situation whether or not that actual
conduct presents a danger is a is a
significant missing step when you simply
label everything as any type of domestic
violence crime as something that should
require being held in jail I'm just
going to give an example I spoke to
someone this morning
arrested for a non
uh but considered to be domestic
violence type of offense you know
arrested and helped already under the
mandatory law that exists in those
circumstances even that individual as
the law currently exists is talking to
me about how you know he has four
children
um those four children are at home he
can't get to work he's the Sole Provider
of the family and is worried about his
ability to provide in those
circumstances I can tell you that I have
clients charged in domestic violence
situations where not every situation not
every charge is necessarily violent or
where any individual is necessarily a
danger by sort of categorizing it
broadly under the domestic violence
statute you're going to be then putting
even people who are not dangerous and
night not flight risks into
incarceration and honestly in those
situations those people also are not
serving jail time in the end either
they're getting the resources that they
need from their community
representative Newell
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um with your I think you said 18 years
of experience in this I'm curious
um especially when we talk about this
being at the discretion of the officer
um I'm I'm curious if in your 18 years
you've seen any kind of patterns
um as to how that how bias manifests in
that excuse me how what how bias
manifests in that situation or if you
haven't then then that's it
involved in a situation is going to have
some natural internal bias in these in
these um matters you know we know that
uh you know people of color in New
Hampshire are still disproportionately
arrested
um yeah on offenses and I think that
specifically in types of offenses that
involve officers oftentimes and so if
they're the ones that making the bail
decisions I think it is concerning
thank you
this time the chair recognizes
oh Trixie
Trixie Leffler
anyone close to them
thank you Trixie Lafave
pay no attention
since they don't run together properly
good morning thank you all for letting
me
participate in this public hearing today
what an honor to be inside the
representatives Hall as well
um
I'm here
over the next few weeks this committee
will hear three bills which seek funding
to hire judges or magistrates plus
additional support staff and new hires
within the circuit courts
today's Bill House Bill 318 also seeks
to eliminate the bail commitment
Commissioners and hire three full-time
judges
this bill contains a fiscal note with a
known expenditure of 323 thousand
dollars per judge so nearly one million
dollars initially
the fiscal note also cites that
additional judges would be needed due to
the increased demands for hearings in
further States and support staff would
be required for these judges
our association of counties projects an
unknown increase in costs to the County
correctional facilities because of an
increase in the incarcerations
the higher these three or more judges
appears to replace the entire bail
commissioner community that serves the
judicial branch as well as the 200 plus
police departments here in New Hampshire
three judges to answer the call of our
Police Department's 24 hours per day
seven days per week the elimination of
bail Commissioners will carry a
tremendous financial burden to New
Hampshire's taxpayers but it will also
place an unknown cost burden on our
County jails which implies more
individuals being detained for longer
periods of time
there are about 80 to 100 bail
commission is presently appointed and
overseen directly by the court that
answer these calls we are
representatives of the judges the
updated 2020 New Hampshire bail
commissioner handbook written by the
administrative office of the courts is
our guidepost and it is our training
bail Commissioners are directly
supervised by a circuit court judge we
respond any time of day any day of the
week regardless of the weather
with the elimination of bail
Commissioners comes this question
how will our police departments be
impacted by this reduction in the court
Workforce typically a bail commissioner
can assist their Department within 45 to
60 minutes
our smaller police departments must keep
the arresting officer present with the
defendant until a bail commissioner
shows up and sets bail should this bill
pass at least police officers unable to
patrol the roads and respond to the
needs of their community
the service that we provide has no tax
impact to New Hampshire residents our
state shares a fiscal intelligence with
two other New England states that uses
bail Commissioners in their judicial
framework
the use of bail Commissioners has proven
to be a valuable tool with no tax burden
for the past four years we have sought
legislative support to help with
uncollected
funds that we are entitled to Perth
statute each attempt has been
unsuccessful to date
in 2021 House Bill 498 was presented
requesting funding in the amount of 636
thousand dollars to cover loss payments
for the 80 to 100 bail Commissioners
that are presently serving it was
defeated
this represents less than eight thousand
dollars per appointed bail commissioner
and it did not pass
bail Commissioners have continued to
perform their services
back here
to their communities despite the
numerous failed attempts to be wholly
compensated
here this morning is a request for the
expenditure of three hundred and twenty
three thousand dollars per each hire
plus additional unknown costs
this bill if passed would reduce the
workforce the courts by about 85 percent
the request makes no practical sense it
is short-sighted it is what is in the
best interest of the Granite Staters
further along in January and February
two more bills will be presented House
Bill 46 and house bill 653.
these also seek additional Staffing in
the courts that have cost more than
three million dollars I point these out
so that all Staffing requests will be
considered at one time House Bill 318
House Bill 46 and house bill 6653 will
add more than four million dollars to
the addition the judicial branch budget
if they all pass
I'm asking that this committee opposed
the passage of House Bill 318 it is
heavy on tax burden and more importantly
it will leave our community as well
without the safety net of their police
officers who will be performing
administrative duties that the
elimination of bail Commissioners would
cause
thank you
thank you for your testimony this
morning
this time the chair recommend uh
recognizes Mr Paul Leary
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record I'm Paul Leary
from Franklin New Hampshire I am a fail
commissioner and I have been for almost
seven years prior to that I had almost
30 years in law enforcement and just for
the record to be a bail commissioner I'm
required to be a Justice of the Peace
which means I have to fill out an
application have a criminal background
check be vetted by the Secretary of
State's office and signed off by
governor and Council
then if I want to be a bail commissioner
I have to be recommended by the court
fill out an application have a
background check be approved by an
administrative judge of the Circuit
Court as well as the Chief Justice of
the superior court so just in reference
for the left-handed compliment that we
had relative to our background
we are vetted to do it
several years ago the legislature passed
that we were supposed to be trained
since that's happened I've had a
19-minute training a 23-minute training
and this year I had the first which I
would call a decent training of over an
hour's time
it was combined by two courts that I
appear before
to let you know I'm out there by myself
128 hours a week
holidays it goes up to 136 hours and if
you add an extra holiday it goes up to
even more
so basically on the training that I've
gotten in my knowledge that I've had
is how I perform the duties but you've
also heard if I'm not doing my job I'd
be removed so the thing is the fact that
I'm standing here as a bail commissioner
for almost seven years I'd say I've been
down in a halfway decent job and not
enough to get dragged in to see the
clerk or we're still the judge or the
administrative judge or the chief
justice so the thing is we are a group
of people out here that are hard working
if we look tight and beat up it's
because we answer the phone 24 7 365.
someone needs a bail commissioner at two
or three o'clock in the morning we're
there we try to provide my concern is if
you do away with the bail commissioners
having been a cop wait too long I go
back to State B Welding a 1982 case
involving some juveniles down in
Kingston that were drinking they hadn't
been drinking they had alcohol in the
vehicle police officers confiscated that
took the kids to the PD returned them
back to the parents kids decided to go
back out later in the evening go across
the line into Massachusetts by alcohol
come back into the state and eventually
unfortunately an accident happened and
someone was killed
end result of the case was it was found
against the town because they said the
police had a common law duty to act
and had they acted they wouldn't have
had the situation
so here we're going to say that police
officers have to let someone go on the
summons and someone may be of
questionable character as a bail
commissioner we have to assure the court
of two things that the defendant is
going to be reasonably
assure the court that they'll appear and
reasonably assure the court that they
won't reoffend
now the police officer is going to have
to figure that out before he gives the
hand summons
you take a small town where you only
have one police officer you take Grafton
County get them down in the southern end
of the county and if they're going to
have to hold them overnight they're
going to have to drive them up to North
Haven
so there's an imposition on a lot of
people if you remove the bail
Commissioners we provide a valuable
service
and I know that uh
attorney head spoke about the
magistrates they're going to have a
position to train the magistrates
you've got us for free basically we're
our own support system we provide all
our own stuff our stamps our postage our
gasoline
some of us since covet because the
Supreme Court told the bail
Commissioners and the police departments
to work it out we've started using tele
bail or remote billing I've done about
838 of them
I get calls from police departments all
over the state because they've tried to
a list of bail Commissioners and they
can't get someone
so I take care of that and I do that
there so there's a valuable service
that's being provided but just to let
you know I'm already coming up on seven
years of March 9th I'm forty eight
thousand dollars in a hole of not being
paid so the thing is with one group in
the state
other than the legislatures but you
signed up at 100 bucks a year now you're
hopefully going to get a raise but
we don't know what we're going to get
because the fee is set by in sin statute
the judge can waive our fee if someone
declares indigency so that even adds
more salt to the wound but we still get
up and we answer the phone when we
appear so it asks you to consider
as Trixie happened to mention the
services that we provide were a known
commodity and if they really were
concerned about us they'd hire a person
to train us on a more regular basis if
they had any questions about the ability
for us to serve as male commissioners
and I thank you for your time and I'm
open for any questions
representative Newell
thank you uh thank you Mr chair and
thank you so much for your testimony
um and thank you for your service I'm
I'm curious
um it sounds like you are a very devoted
bail commissioner and uh stepped up to
do something without a lot of pay
um and so my my question is uh
considering that it does end up costing
you a lot do you see that as a
sustainable model that other people
would want to take that on I'm sorry
unfortunately I have these sixty two
hundred dollar hearing aids anyone
standing here I haven't heard speak very
much and you the last half of what you
said disappeared into the room I
apologize um hopefully I can make it a
little clearer
um what I'm curious about is if you see
this as a sustainable model that other
people seeing as you have sacrificed so
much to serve your community
um in the way of you know extending your
own resources do you see this as
something that is sustainable in that
other people will be willing to take
that on when you pass the torch
unfortunately representative I still
can't hear them can you hear me can you
hear me I can hear you okay gee I'll
I'll reiterate she asked if based on the
hardships you have
um getting paid and all the work you put
in if you see this as a sustainable
model going forward if you there'll be
anyone else interested in being a bail
commissioner
if you truly believe in the New
Hampshire way
and people believe in the common good
I think people will step up and we'll do
it but the problem is after a period of
time they'll get burnt out and fed up
because they're not treated with respect
by the people that they're trying to
serve but more importantly also the
people that they're working with there
are some things that they could do to
make it easier for us
to help in the collection of the Bales
that are due
easy way would be just make it a cut
cost and the court system pays us forty
dollars every time we do a bail and the
story we get paid people are happy and
then we still have but we still have our
own expenses but the answer to your
question is I think the citizens in New
Hampshire care enough about the system
that if they know about it and they can
meet the qualifications
and that's the key to it just because
you're a Justice of the Peace doesn't
mean you know enough to be able to sign
a warrant just because you're a justice
of the peace and you become appointed a
bail commission it doesn't mean that you
have all the answers until you're either
trained or you learn the hard way the
school of odd knocks but I have faith in
the citizens of New Hampshire that they
will be there to step up and do it
as do I thank you
for the questions thank you for your
testimony
the chair recommend recognizes Professor
share from them
himself
good morning members of the committee uh
thank you Mr chair
um I'm going to try and uh tailor my
comments given what's already been said
I am a professor at UNH law professor at
UNH law I've been there this is my 29th
year
um before that I was a public defender
for 13 years so all told I've been
involved in the New Hampshire criminal
justice system for over 40 years in
various capacities I am also recently
about a year and a half ago elected as a
police commissioner in Portsmouth there
are three of us and we are Loosely the
board of directors for the police
department in Portsmouth so I have a
variety of experiences in the criminal
justice system
um I'm not going to go into the cost
issues I'm very supportive of uh what Mr
head said about the Court's cost issues
it's a real significant problem I get
that I don't think that portion of this
bill which seeks to solve it by adding
three any additional judges really
addresses it in a full and comprehensive
way through staffing issues that go with
that so I would rely on on I would defer
to what Mr head said and the court
system says on that that's part one of
this bill part two of this bill is the
change in the underlying bail statute
for purposes of background I
I worked with Senator feltis five years
ago in drafting the Bell Reform Bill
that was passed so and I've been working
with this committee
testifying in before this Committee in
front of the Senate Judiciary Committee
unveil issues for five years it's
something I care deeply about and I
appreciate the complications that come
with it even putting aside the cost
issues as to the change that
representative Lynn's Bill proposes with
adding those I think there's 12 crimes
where the system would deal with them
differently and hold people until they
see a judge I think I would say most
simply that over incarcerates people
without any data to support that we need
to take that extra step to over
incarcerate people at the front end of
the case when we know far less about the
case
to capture the and and I know this
committee has struggled over the years
with having to make decisions without
data that's one of the fundamental
problems we have in this area is we
don't have data about what's really
going on
those are who've been on the committee
for a while have heard anecdote after
anecdote about the horrors of the bail
statute and that's uh I I'll be blunt
about it that's a false narrative
uh
I worked with a student
I hired a student over the summer and
this past semester to actually gather
data we gathered data we gathered
508 what are called case summary sheets
which are summarizes what is happening
in an individual case and we got 500 we
got over a thousand and we were able to
process
508 of them that tell us what's going on
in the case from Soup To Nuts you know
what they were arrested for what the
bill was set at what then transpired in
the case
and the story that that data
says and I offer to you this is the
First Data actual hard data that this
committee has heard in five years of
dealing with Bill reform issues what
that data says is several
very powerful pieces of information
out of the 508 case summary sheets that
we looked at
in only four of them
four out of 508 was there any evidence
that the person who had been released on
bail
was charged with a subsequent crime
so this issue of you know the sky is
falling dangerous people all given bail
reform dangerous people are out there
committed Crime After Crime because bail
is letting them the bail system is
letting them out is a false narrative
there are anecdotes no question about
that no system as large as the New
Hampshire criminal justice system is is
going to be perfect it's not possible
but four out of 508 number two
um
out of those 508 cases there are a mix
of completed cases uh from I think 2018
or 2019 from Manchester District Court
and Superior Court uh Hillsborough
County security Court North the
Manchester Superior Court we picked
those because that is the most in terms
of testimony we've heard over the years
it's the most
contested area in terms of bail reform I
know the Manchester police department
has very strong opinions about it
out of the 508 cases
35 of them all the charges were
dismissed
35 percent of them
that means if you increase the number as
this bill does as House Bill 318 does if
you increase the number of people who
are being held at least in the short
term if not longer by virtue of
identifying these serious crimes
remember many of them
not only are people as Professor Davis
said are people who are subsequently not
going to get any jail time many of them
are people whose cases will be dismissed
completely yet they will have spent
anywhere from one to four days in jail
creating the havoc in their lives that
Professor Davis talked about
third
out of the 330 plus cases that we looked
at from
Superior Court in Manchester
fully 78 of them were drug cases
relatively speaking victimless
crime cases
other than
the defendants or themselves who are the
primary victims in drug cases they're
certainly exceptions to that but
78 of those cases were drug cases drug
cases are overwhelming
the court system
and they are not the kind of cases that
uh
are the Solutions in those cases
are rarely involved successful Solutions
rarely involved incarcerating people
I think as Professor David said David
said the
criminal legal system the criminal
justice system is not good is not
designed and is not good at solving
the problem of one house people of
solving the problem of people with
significant addictions of solving the
problem with people with significant
mental health issues yet in the absence
of other systems available we've been
trying to jury rate the criminal justice
system uh to do that and and and it's
not working particularly well we're over
incarcerating people
finally the um
there is plenty of opportunity and
statutory Authority Under the current
bail statute as it exists to handle
dangerous people rather than using what
uh representative Lynn's Bill does is
for certain crimes using a
one-size-fits-all approach
the system is currently set up that
judges make decisions in individual
cases and that's working based on the
data that we've collected so
I encourage you not to be seduced by the
false narrative that something is
fundamentally wrong with our bail system
as it exists it's working
um don't be deluded by uh
by anecdote horror stories
because they exist and they're always
going to exist no matter what kind of
build system we have
but overall the system is working really
well finally
I am in support of Representative uh
Herod gathright's uh magistrate bill I
think it's in the long term the right
approach to handle one part of the bail
system that has had somewhat erratic
issues that is bail Commissioners as I
think representative Lynn said there are
some excellent very devoted bail
Commissioners and you've heard from them
but I'm also aware that there there are
uh
uh Bell Commissioners who are less
available and are not uh real in the
eyes of both police departments
um and defense lawyers are are not
understanding the nature of the
authority they have under the male
statute so I would urge you uh to vote
itl on this bill and I will be here next
week to testify uh in favor of
Representative Harriet gath Wright's
bill
um I you know I think we either need to
pass that bill
um and extend
the time of implementation significantly
or we need to put together a study
committee that pulls in the courts the
criminal defense Community the
prosecutors the police to uh really have
a staff a comprehensive Staffing be it
judges or staff solution I'll talk about
that more next week more than willing to
answer questions
there have been no questions thank you
for your testimony and we'll see you
next week thank you
chairman calls Mr Frank Nick from the
ACLU
Mr chairman members of the committee is
this on
thank you for the opportunity to testify
today my name is Frank Knack I'm the
policy director uh with the ACLU of New
Hampshire and we are here in opposition
to HB 318. Professor sharer talked about
um the anecdotes that you've heard and
that I'm sure you will hear this session
around bail reform and to not kind of
look at those anecdotes as what's really
happening on the ground and I can't
reiterate that strongly enough and I
think you know the the thing that's been
missing with a lot of the debate is what
are the specific facts in each of those
cases and how has current bail law
failed in those cases and we have not
heard any evidence of that and so if you
look in the packet that I gave you
now you'll see a few things you'll see
our fact sheet but you'll also see a
document that lists uh by code section
all of the numerous tools currently in
the law that allow people who have
reoffended to be held
um it clarifies very clearly in black
and white that anyone under current law
anyone who is a danger or a Flight Risk
to the community can be held regardless
of the fence and another issue that was
raised last year and we didn't get a
sufficient answer I believe from the um
from those proponents of this
legislation is that under current law a
prosecutor the state can challenge any
release order that they disagree with
and so when we're hearing these
anecdotal stories we're not hearing in
each of those cases you know did they
challenge the release order because from
our perspective we have heard that they
are did they challenge you know did they
use the tools they have to have the
person uh incarcerated when they're
reoffended because they have that tool
right now and so we think those are
really important factors to include this
debate the other the other issue that I
want to lift up among a few others is
that we've also heard that bail reform
has made our communities less safe
and so while we have only been provided
some anecdotes without detail to to make
that challenge we've seen no hard data
and so the data that we do have right
now is the data from the Department of
Safety around our crimes and arrests and
so if you go back to 2018 the year of
bail reform and you actually look at the
crime data overall New Hampshire You
know despite the rhetoric we've heard
crime is down 18 for group a offenses so
that's the vast majority of offenses 18
percent and in the jurisdiction where we
heard the Chiefs testified last year in
Manchester and Bedford in Manchester
crimes down 13 since bail reform in
Bedford it's down over 21 since Bill
reform and so the notion that bail
reform has somehow made our communities
less safe again is not supported by the
facts I also really think it's important
we had
representative Lynn talked earlier about
ftas and the fact that this legislation
is further restricting the discussion
that judges have around ftas and
allowing folks to um to not be
necessarily held under ftas so the
Rockefeller Center at Dartmouth did a
study of ftas a few years ago
and this is what they found of the top
five reasons that people fail to appear
four of them are Child Care
Transportation employment or they forgot
and so taking away a judge's discretion
to determine the facts in that case and
whether or not that person should be
held particularly before the top five
are things of these nature we think is
very problematic and again they're data
driven tools so when people forget
there's lots of research going on right
now around ways to help handle that like
test text message alerts you know the
MacArthur safety and Justice challenges
have been doing this across the country
um
it also I really want to I think it's
important to point out
that not only have they not provided any
data to support their claims but they're
also ignoring the robust research that
has been you know decades in the making
including a major study last year by
Arnold ventures in Kentucky that looked
at 1.5 million people who were jailed
between 20 2009 and 2018 and so prior to
this study there was a common belief
that you know if you are held by more
than 24 hours the likelihood of
reoffending increased because as we
heard you know you're removed from your
community removed from your job either
collateral harms are severe what this
most recent study found in 1.5 million
people overnight a 10-year period is
that any incarceration pre-trial
increases the likelihood that someone
will reoffend because they're being
removed from their community and so
that's not saying that no one should be
held it's saying that the way our
current law is written which ensures
discretion but that anyone can be held
if the judge in that individual case
finds them to be a danger or a Flight
Risk is the standard that we should
maintain in New Hampshire happy to
answer any questions
there'll be no questions thank you for
your testimony this morning
is there anyone else who hasn't filled
out a pin card or wish to testify
representative scitec
hi uh Mr chairman members of the
I know this is running long but it's
important so I'm sorry I hope my remarks
are worth listening to
uh I have been a bail commissioner for
22 years I've done
3375 bales
I don't want to pick there are a couple
of quick slides that I would like to
swat first there is no four recording uh
Judge Lynn or excuse me representative
didn't know it didn't say it there are
no formal procedures for removing a bail
commissioner but practically speaking
all that happens is the judge calls the
police department says don't call this
guy if you go to the Judicial website
you'll see a list of decommissioned uh
bail commissioners
there is uh I want to take some I'm
taking real exception at the idea that
magistrates no better can set fails
better than uh fail Commissioners and
pardon my umbrage but look I have I made
it a point when I was first starting and
I still continue here and there to check
what the Superior Court does with my
recommendations
in total now I don't know how many I've
done maybe you have a couple dozen of
checks no judge has ever changed I have
had two of my Bales changed one was
increase and the other was moved from
the bail to preventive detention so
I'm
I trust the bail commissioners
I heard a statistic that 4 out of 508
where'd he go uh the uh look
yesterday
there's a guy arrested for domestic
violence who was out on bail for
shoplifting I wasn't prepared to think
about this but I know there's been a
couple others in the past month that can
have committed
offenses while on bail it's not the main
purpose of what I'm saying but I heard
those remarks those it's hard to take
statistics seriously sometimes you want
to and you then you see your own
experience and you wonder
uh
I am testifying in opposition and uh to
this bill I hope my experience I'd like
to share my experience I hope that it's
helpful I think
from what I've heard I'm going to try to
offer some different Slants and some
mention some things that weren't talked
about at all
I believe this bill will work against
the liberty interest of those arrested
by detaining them longer whether they're
retained waiting for a bail Commissioner
of Clerk of Courts a magistrate whoever
it's just this real an incarceration as
if they were found by by judicial
process
uh the uh I'm going to say that the
present system of bail commissions with
a hundred of them uh covering the state
is like democracy it may not be the best
system but it's better than the
Alternatives that I have seen offered
uh the why of this bill is important I'm
about a quarter of the way through by
the way uh the why of this bill is
important before today bail
Commissioners have attracted almost no
legislative interest or concern there's
been recent controversy concerning bail
reform and it continues today
P38 coming up
bail commissioner has been caught in the
crossfire of competing considerations in
an effect have been held responsible for
cash bails excessive cash bails in my
experience this is not so bail
Commissioners follow the their
instructional handbook and the
instructions of their District Court
Judge they followed the rules
at a conference a couple years ago look
I live in the real world I've done this
for a long time
at a conference a couple years ago I
won't mention the judge's name he said I
don't have the exact quote but it was
like this I don't know where we exactly
where we stand in all this talking about
judicial form cash fails all of that
whole miasma
uh so what is likely to happen uh
right now
uh uh let's see where am I for a bail
which includes a bail includes the right
to speak to the bail commissioner about
their bail conditions what cash is
involved or otherwise
in the proposed system the arrested
arrested person will wait longer and we
try as bail Commissioners to be there
within 30 minutes or have 45 minutes is
the kind of time if it's longer than
that we pass it off at least I do it how
do I know this
from time to time I bail somebody's had
experience in Massachusetts and you'd be
amazed at how many suspended licenses
this occurs
uh they are amazed when they see me and
they thank me because they say in
Massachusetts they have waited hours for
the clerk of court to show up
the proposed system will soon likely
spring a leak
what I mean by that is this
where were you at two o'clock this
morning
I'll tell you where I was I was driving
to Parkland Hospital from Salem to Derry
to bail a bedside Bale for a domestic
violence uh
suspect the issue was they wanted him
bailed before he had an operation in the
course of the altercation here he also
hurt himself which for him I suppose but
they wanted him out of police custody so
I'm going up by the way I didn't get
paid it was that was just on the house
that's life
I knew that we all knew that it comes
with the territory when we became bail
Commissioners when as a side of Judge
Corby asked me long ago to be a bell
commission I didn't know what it was he
just evaluated that I had some common
sense I guess and I did it because I
thought it was a good thing to do for
the community the money was I guess
that's nice beer money I suppose but
it's not why I do it or why others to
perhaps the art let me leave that
um
okay the
I I guess what I'm talking about I don't
see a district court judge or
perhaps even a magistrate getting up at
two in the morning to afford a
constitutional right to somebody who
requires who is entitled to a bail we
take that seriously
I take it seriously
um
you've heard that these Fair
Commissioners don't cost the state
anything
but this bill will cost over a million
you've heard that but what you didn't
remember well you may not have
remembered is that there's a competing
constitutional right and that's the
right to public defenders we heard
when we had our orientation that the
public defender's office wants 15
million bucks do you think they're going
to get it where are we going to find a
million for this or a million
it's unlikely
so I think public defenders are more
important than a system that is
presently working
uh
okay I am reflecting firstly the four
Salem bail Commissioners I know
sprinkling of others in Rockingham
County there's no formal organization
but we talk
and I'm not very different from other
bail Commissioners that I know
the bill also has some technical
problems and I'll leave with that
um
and that is this
line 12 H2 if I remember correctly so
here's what happens it's eight o'clock
at night guy gets pulled over State
Police pull him over
he's driving uh he's got a cash to
settle fine he didn't pay a 120 fine
okay there's a warrant out for his
arrest
it's a hard water uh ebw I can't do
anything about it the judge
if he has 120 bucks he's freed I write
up the papers he goes his way
you read line 12 and it tells you the
chords will accept this where's the
court at eight o'clock at night you want
to slide it under the door for him
just that that guy's going to be in jail
because he got an ebw A piece of paper
that says don't let him out if he says
he doesn't have the money
you have to let him go and write him up
for let's mark him up for another
arraignment
but ironically the way the bill is
written if he has the money he can't get
out because he can't give it to the
court
at the bottom of that page line we're
starting at line 28 what about domestic
violence
you'd be amazed at how many pajamas I've
seen along the way guy gets pulled in at
11 o'clock at night for domestic
violence
Court can set him free you're going to
have a judge come out
a
these are important people by the way
they don't like to be disturbed that way
I've never seen the police call a
district court judge they're minor Gods
anyway
there are technical problems with the
implementation of the bill it would
really take
sitting down with real world experience
analyzing seeing exactly what happens
after an arrest how is it handled
and that is why I'm opposed to the bill
both from a conceptual point of view and
from a technical point of view thank you
for listening if you have any questions
I'll be in committee from the exact
session
thank you representative
that being the last speaker on the bill
I'm hereby closing the public hearing on
an HP
in opening the public hearing on hb560
and
looks like we have a co-sponsor going to
speak
um
Stephen
poker
representative
the chair calls Stephen bogert
representative Stephen bogert
y
represent proud are you introducing this
bill
is just to present house bill 560. yes
yes I will do that for Cody today okay
thank you
first of all I just handed this so uh
um I'll read it I'll read his statement
everywhere it says I that will be from
representative
um this is House Bill 560 FNA
and the bill requires the state police
to establish a contact person
notification program to assist the law
enforcement Personnel who have contact
with a person with mental or physical
disabilities make an appropriation
thereafter
uh the state police are here today
they're going to be in favor and speak
to this
today
uh this bill 516 being presented in
hopes to establish a contact person
notification program to assist law
enforcement Personnel who come in
contact with a person with mental mental
illness or physical disabilities
make an appropriation thereof
as many of us have seen in recent years
there have been many negative
interactions between law enforcement and
individuals with disabilities across
this country many times these
interactions have been deadly and very
controversial several States across the
county including our neighboring state
of Maine have passed a similar law which
gives law enforcement another tool to
avoid negative interactions with people
persons who have disabilities
Bill required the New Hampshire State
Police to develop and Implement a
program was a state police online
telecommune system that's known as spots
to assist law enforcement officers who
come into contact with a person with
mental or physical disabilities
this program will be voluntary based
whereby the person with disability or a
legal parent or guardian of a person
with a disability May Supply their local
law enforcement agency with certain
information pertaining to the person's
disability
such as autism hearing impaired
Alzheimer's and other disabilities
and who the law enforcement officer may
contact during interaction with such a
person
the law enforcement agency who receives
such information will enter the person
with disabilities in the New Hampshire
State Police thoughts database
the information entered into the spots
will be available to all law enforcement
agencies across the state of New
Hampshire
who has contact with a participating
person
at any time just a person or the legal
parent of the guardian of such person
may request the person's information to
be removed from spots database
the goal of this program is to give law
enforcement offices a resource to avoid
negative interactions with persons with
a disability
I am asking for the members of this
committee to help give Law Enforcement
Officers a resource to help protect a
person with disabilities
as a veteran law enforcement officer the
writer of this document any payment of
an autistic child I feel this program
will be an asset to law enforcement and
individuals with disabilities
after doing some research and speaking
with resources from other states where
this program has been developed and
implemented
we have learned the cost to start this
program has been estimated between 25
and 50 000 depending on the database and
other states use
asking for fifty thousand dollars allows
us New Hampshire State Police to develop
and implement this plan as stated in the
physical note the New Hampshire State
Police would not require additional
Personnel to manage this program they
state it would increase the workload
slightly for the current employees
thank you for introducing and testifying
in that bill representative the chair
recognizes
Lieutenant Matthew La Perrier from the
New Hampshire State Police
so the state police
supports this bill
just had to testify on that behalf it's
beneficial for everyone in the state
um
we spend a lot of time if we do have a
situation with someone that might have
Alzheimer's dementia
autism any of those scenarios where
we're wasting hours and hours and hours
not wasting but it's usually hours and
hours
just to locate a family member to help
in the situation
never mind if we don't know there's a
disability situations that
get ramped up and
cause you know further could be injury
or costs are associated with not knowing
what this person has so if somebody
wants to voluntarily provide information
about something that we can have in a
system that we run the person we know
what we're walking into or what we're
dealing with that would alleviate a lot
for all our enforcement across the state
I understand this this would be within
New Hampshire as of now so that's how we
connect everyone is through our spot
system all of the law enforcement State
County local we're all connected through
our spot system so the the financial
piece from my understanding is we would
have our vendor
that handles our spots so our software
company would add another module so this
module would be one more module versus
the others that we have so if we have a
missing person module in our system this
one is just one more separate module so
that's what the expense is once it's in
there
it'll be pushed out to all agencies all
the dispatch centers and everybody
so it's a it's a quick spin up on a
system that's already been in existence
for decades that everybody understands
and knows how to use
so I think
it's all positive I can't see anything
negative
well if anyone has any questions
um
just so for the the committee
understands so what this would do is if
you get a call to a residence for a
disturbance and there's a person there
dispatch would call that person up in
the system something would flash and say
this person has this contact for this
issue and you would know before you got
there what you were dealing with in
discounts could potentially call the
person to help assist is that pretty
much how that would work because because
a lot of times if it's someone say
Alzheimer's dementia even
we have wrong way drivers and I've been
out there you know you get them boxed in
on the high speed limit on 93 and you're
going through that wallet you're trying
to look for it because they don't even
know where they are what's going on so
you're trying to find something to help
out this person
because you need to figure it out so if
we have something that's in place
it helps all the way around so either
we're responding to something or we come
upon it
it's it's a huge help
How would how would someone get into the
system is this something where a
relative would have to call the State
Police or could they go through their
local police it would be every law
enforcement agency in the state just
currently just how we have it say if it
is a missing person or endangered person
that same procedure
so they go to the local police
department it'll be a form they fill it
out it's all voluntary gets entered and
then we have it
hopefully some of that money might be
used for advertising I wonder to get
that information out that this is
available correct
um thank you for answering my questions
Representatives
um
I represent Rhodes
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
pretty simply is in the event that you
know that this you know you're you're
going someplace and you know that
there's this contact person
that person's unavailable what would be
your next step would you you know is
there going to be a backup person or
would it just be simply you would just
kind of wait until you're able to get a
hold of the contact person
so I'm just seeing this now if it's the
one person that's the one person however
we'll still know what we're dealing with
as far as
the the disability because that's a huge
help
because like I said it could take hours
just to get to that point
um that would save a lot of time
especially when you know across the
board our our law enforcement agencies
are now Staffing so I think it's just
another tool into the tool chest that
would help us
yep
representative Murphy
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question as a parent of an
adult child with the traumatic traumatic
brain injury and autism and over whom I
have guardianship I see Great Value in a
bill like this recognizing the
communication disorders and challenges
um that these individuals have as well
as the challenges that law enforcement
has when entering into a situation
involving them and not being aware of a
disability that may not be visual
are you uh
I hear that you're supporting this this
um this bill and uh would would you
would you think that having more than
one contact in in a system would be
helpful should you know like in my case
if the parent wasn't available
um the the attempt would be made to
reach that person yes definitely
beneficial the more the better so even
more than two more than three whatever
that may be that's more beneficial great
thank you very much
under the current systems there's the
ability to enter in more information so
there wouldn't be a problem adding more
than one name or number right right so
in the spot system even if you had the
Box level one contact you have a
comments field
so you could have you know two three
four so the system set up that way they
can add
representative Bolden
thank you thank you for taking my
question
um is there any equivalent uh currently
in place at city or town levels and
how does your jurisdiction relate to
properties that are not on the highway
for this legislation so in this
legislation it's being proposed that
it's the
gonna use the spots right so that's the
state police online terminal that's what
all law enforcement of the state uses so
Department of Safety Division of State
Police that's what's under
us one housing of that that's that one
Central Point that manages it and then
from there all the other law enforcement
agencies
tie into it so this is being proposed
this way because
the division of State Police oversees
that so jurisdiction-wise yeah we have
you know certain towns true Beth we
might have 65 towns with a primary
police Agency for those towns other
areas we are not so the interstates it
just depends on who where it is and it's
broken up in the state where you would
know to go to have that entered so up
North true math they know to go to Twin
Mountain
that's the point of contact for that
area
follow up
thank you um so just to clarify because
the
um you're saying all in law enforcement
entities in the state use the same
system it doesn't
um matter where someone is found when
they're in need of help
they'll um
their their contact person can always be
um determined yeah through this system
it's that one
system so if I'm a
if I'm a Manchester police officer on my
cruise and I run somebody in my mobile
data terminal that's the same thing I
would have if I was a true F Trooper on
93 in Lincoln it's that's it I get the
same exact response it's that one system
same as a wanted person that would come
up uh vehicle check all of it it's all
housed in that one system
representative salig
thank you so much for taking my question
um so this bill talks about people with
mental and physical disabilities does it
it's not clear to me if this would also
include and I don't know if you know the
answer to this people who are having
mental health
um impairments so you know someone who
might have like a form of schizophrenia
or dissociative disorders or is is that
so so my understanding just because I
only read the legislation if it's a
disability I would consider that a
disability I have had contact with
people with bipolar and other scenarios
right and that's a that would be huge to
know that that's what they are right to
diagnose someone
you know instantaneously is very
difficult if you have years of
experience you could pick up on things
because someone might be wearing
sunglasses and it's at nighttime right
and you're asking them questions and it
doesn't make sense so
if you have this I have a hard fact so I
would say that all those things
would be welcomed
representative Gendron
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
I have a lot of folks in my family that
are diabetic
um and one of the things that I I think
that police have had issues with in the
past if somebody is hypoglycemic
which means their blood sugar is low
they can actually act as if they are
intoxicated
with this system allow that information
to be placed in there that they are a
diabetic and instead of giving them a
sobriety test you'd be able to call an
ambulance for them yeah and I and I know
exactly what you're talking about
because I've dealt with it multiple
times firsthand so you don't smell
alcohol right but the person's
being very aggressive even when you're
interacting with them and
um
so like I said
however they wrote this bill if it's a
disability I would say it would qualify
for it so if if that's what the the
nature is I think that's beneficial
because why do we want to have to have
I've had it where it has been diabetic
and we recognize it soon enough where we
don't because you don't have to go
Hands-On at all right
we're not going to arrest the person
with the DUI if they're diabetic so we
get EMTs there and the person is more
comfortable with that so it alleviates a
situation and it brings it down so
I would see benefit of that correct
there being no further questions thank
you for your testimony this morning
thank you
is there anyone else wishing to testify
on this bill
there being none I'm going to close
public here in HP 560.
open public hearing on HB 643
I recognize the representative of Damon
to introduce our bill
good morning thank you chairman Roy and
thank you to the full committee for your
efforts to be here today and overall I
hope your Drive-In was a titch easier
than mine New Hampshire weather
keeps it interesting
as a freshman representative serving on
education committee I have considerable
respect for your commitment and work
I am representative hope Damon serving
the citizens of Sullivan District 8
which includes the beautiful towns of
Acworth Langdon Leominster Goshen
Washington Springfield Sunapee my
hometown of Croydon and the rising City
of Claremont and yes I share
representation of District 8 with your
criminal justice colleague
representative Stone
I am sponsoring House Bill 643 to
legalize marijuana for persons 21 and
over on behalf of many constituents I
acknowledge that there are several other
pending marijuana bills with different
approaches to be considered
prior to being elected representative I
enjoyed a rewarding 40-year career as a
private practice dietitian diabetes
educator and eating disorder specialist
that work means my decision making is
grounded in evidence-based science
I note that because I have come to
support and now promote marijuana
legislation very thoughtfully
I care deeply about how people take care
of themselves I have great respect for
individual freedoms
that background and those values lead me
to say New Hampshire is very overdue to
legalized marijuana
prohibition doesn't work
people are utilizing recreational
marijuana anyway
and we are way behind all the other New
England states
in making it safer by regulating the
products that are available
and in generating revenue for other
purposes from sales of marijuana
so this bill sets up retail sales solely
through the state of New Hampshire with
operations and regulations similar to
alcohol and handled by the liquor
condition
a state would be reimbursed for all
costs involved in setting up the retail
sales by 2027.
after that
50 percent of the revenues would be
provided to the education trust fund
funds would be dispersed to
municipalities with the lowest total
valuation per pupil
and the calculation is defined in the
bill
funds shall be dispersed in ascending
order until exhausted it is well known
that the state of New Hampshire does not
equitably and adequately fund education
as I'm serving on education committee I
am really closely seeing the challenges
in adverse effects on our schools our
students and our taxpayers
the other 50 percent of marijuana
revenues should this bill pass would go
to a new fund at the Department of
Health and Human Services for increased
access to mental health care
it has been widely publicized including
several very recent tragedies that New
Hampshire does not have an adequate
system of providing mental health care
services
and I will say in my career as a
dietitian particularly in my work with
eating disorders but also there's a
higher incidence of depression and
anxiety disorders in people who have
diabetes
it was just a constant constant
challenge to find providers for mental
health care services we just simply
don't have enough people
providing those services and part of
that is a funding issue for that
profession
going back to this bill there is also
a fund that would be set up at Health
and Human Services to present a public
media campaign including social media on
safe storage of marijuana risks to avoid
not driving pregnancy
people under 21
Etc and that campaign would begin before
retail sales started
I will acknowledge that the bill is not
perfect as written I'm a freshman
legislator and I'm learning on the job
and open to feedback and questions I do
believe the effective date needs to be
pushed out it's not realistic
but overall this is a thorough and
responsible approach to legalizing
marijuana and benefiting from the
revenues we owe it to the citizens of
New Hampshire to stop treating
recreational marijuana as a crime
and we owe it to our citizens to benefit
from this Revenue opportunity
to responsibly fund essentially needed
public education and Mental Health
Services
thank you for your time and attention
representative Rhodes thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question I'm looking at the very first
page
under one in its D or it says I'm sorry
it's e
cannabis should cannabis sold in the
state shall be tested labeled and
subject to additional regulations can
you give me an example of
you know is the tested part in in this
for the funding and what is what is an
additional regulation
and that's part of what I was
referencing when I spoke about safety
presently when people
purchase marijuana on the black market
which is happening all over the state
they don't know what it is really
so this is to make it safer in that
regard
Mr chairman if I just may clarify
um use an additional regulations
I'm just not sure exactly what you mean
by that it very well could be in here
honestly I haven't got to the whole
thing but the bill is long honestly I
don't know the answer to that either
okay thank you
representative Newell
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um my question is
um is the uh safe you know so let me put
it this way
um there's a lot of money that goes into
policing uh cannabis use possession sale
that kind of stuff
um I'm wondering if the
expenditures that are saved in that so
that the money that is not spent on
police over police and community that
kind of thing is that factored into the
financial the financials in this
I don't believe the fifth School node
addressed that
so it would be appropriate to evaluate
that
thank you
representative salig
thank you representative for your time
and partaking my question it's actually
a follow-up to representative Newell's
question
um have you if this bill were to be
passed and so we would no longer need to
put people into jails for marijuana
violations do you have any information
about what kind of cost saving that is
or do you know
um you know cumulatively or if you have
any information or or ideas about the
best way to determine the reduction in
cost which would not just be at the
state levels but also at the county
levels
thank you for your question it's
clear that we should know the answer to
that and it's not included here
thank you for your testimony
thank you
and the chair recognizes Heather Marie
Brown
can you hear me all right good morning
my name is Heather Marie Brown and I am
the vice chairman for the therapeutic
cannabis medical oversight board this is
a board that works with health and human
services that was established
legislatively several years ago to
oversee Public Health the safety matters
and so forth I'm here on my own
recognance and to represent the Thirteen
thousand plus patients that we have in
this state and I can tell you from a
personal level that although I am
extremely supportive of legalizing
cannabis in the state of New Hampshire I
do not necessarily agree that this bill
is the way to do that
I have a couple of issues with the bill
and those issues would be on
as introduced page
one
number line 14 all retail Cannabis
stores shall be operated by the state of
New Hampshire I have not
seen a state where legalization has come
forward where they have had a successful
cannabis program
controlled and run by the state in such
a fashion as a potential liquor store
model I just it hasn't worked I believe
that if legalization comes to the state
of New Hampshire that it should be open
to New Hampshire residents and to
promote small business growth and
development within the citizens not to
create a monopoly-like structure for the
State of New Hampshire
I also have another issue on
page three
line 23
it says cannabis products containing THC
purchased from a retail cannabis store
which shall be limited to therapeutic
use only for which the purchaser
presents documentation permitting use of
cannabis for therapeutic purposes
this bill basically what this is saying
is that these monopolized stores
controlled by the state of New Hampshire
can potentially poach therapeutic
cannabis patients and provide a
detrimental effect to the therapeutic
cannabis program
that should not be allowed adult use
should be exactly that adult use
therapeutic should be exactly that
therapeutic use the two of them should
not intermingle in any way shape or form
I think it's inappropriate for that to
be in there or to even be considered we
don't want to create a problem within
the therapeutic cannabis program because
regardless of adult use whether it and
now it's not a question of whether or
not it will happen it's a question of
when it will happen and
and we still will need a therapeutic
cannabis program intact running and
operated because that program provides
the information the research and the
resources that patients need in order to
create a proper treatment regimen for
themselves in their health and in their
health and wellness this bill there is
nothing in this bill that says any of
the people working for these stores are
going to have the education the
knowledge or be able to provide
information to therapeutic cannabis
patients in the manner of which they
receive now through our local
dispensaries
so although I do think this is a good
attempt and although I do support
legalization I do not believe that this
bill is the best way to do that I think
that it creates a whole bunch of new
problems I think that
those items should be struck in and I
would rather see a much better system
come to place in the state of New
Hampshire in regards to adult use
I will gladly answer any questions you
may have
and I thank you for the opportunity to
speak
representative Newell
uh you know clearly we do have a couple
of different iterations of similar bills
do you think that this one can be
amended to be appropriate and to satisfy
your concerns or do you think that
um that we would need a completely
different bill
well as many of you may know there have
been several legalization bills that
have been presented this session and I
personally find that all of them have
their own issues and problems within
each particular bill I I hate to say it
but I do believe that if you took all of
those bills and you stripped them apart
and you took bits and pieces from each
bill you could come up with a very
satisfactory structure in order to
promote adults adult use in the state of
New Hampshire and not interfere with the
therapeutic cannabis program as it is
now
to
thank you for your testimony
anyone else wishing to testify on this
bill
there being none I hereby
close the public hearing on
hb643 and open public hearing on HP 581
interesting
who's introducing it
are you introduced
is this your bill yeah and I recognize
representative stanzo to introduce his
bill
thank you uh chairman and members of the
criminal justice committee uh my name is
representative Samson nastasso
representing the towns of Rindge Dublin
and Jaffrey
and uh House Bill 581 is a simple bill
it deletes uh the controlled Drug Act in
New Hampshire and established the study
committee on the implementation of
deleting the controlled Drug Act this
builds the ultimate solution to the drug
legalization question all these bills
are getting filed that are nitpicking in
different ways and stuff this is where
it's going to go ultimately just as the
18th Amendment of the United States
Constitution was repealed
um the 18th Amendment which prohibited
the manufacturer's sale and
transportation of intoxicating Liquors
is pretty interesting for a couple of
reasons one that at the time they
recognized that they couldn't just
prohibit uh straight up possession so
there's it wasn't illegal to possess
liquor during prohibition the other
thing that's interesting is that they
actually
passed an amendment to the Constitution
because
at the time in the 1920s they actually
had respect for the Constitution and
they did things like have Congress
declare war and uh used sound money that
was is mandated by the Constitution that
we use gold
um so in order for uh in section two
I'll just read to the 18th Amendment so
uh section one after one year from the
ratification of this article the
manufacturers sale a transportation of
intoxicating Liquors
uh within the importation thereof into
or the exportation thereof from the
United States and all territories
subject to the jurisdiction thereof for
beverages purposes is hereby prohibited
and then section two uh the Congress and
the several States shall have the
concurrent power to enforce this article
by the appropriate legislation so this
suggests that it was illegal for the
states and the government to prohibit
liquor without actually amending the
Constitution
and therefore the
all the
controlled substance acts in New
Hampshire's included are illegal all
right uh so any private property is
natural to man laws that prohibit
possession of certain items such as
drugs or Firearms or infringement on an
individual right to own and use their
property as they see fit as long as an
individual is not harming others or
common disturbance they should be able
to possess whatever they choose on their
own property without government
interference
um criminalizing possession leads to the
over criminalization of society people
who are not committing any harm end up
getting labeled as criminals and face
the consequences that come with the
label such as fines imprisonment
criminal record which have uh severe and
life lasting impact on on them uh and
then some of these prohibited substances
are controlled acts uh like DMT for
example have an enormous tradition of
religious use uh that out you know
longer than uh the United States even
existed uh so and just having this in
Statue is completely a violation of the
New Hampshire Constitution uh article
one a part one Article Five
um additionally they use Laws
disproportionately affect marginalized
communities uh some even argue that the
purpose of drug war was intentionally to
control minority communities
um but is known that individuals from
low income and minority groups are just
partially targeted and arrested for drug
possession despite similar usage rates
across different groups uh so an
anecdotally uh group that I'm very
familiar with was the a second Airborne
Division which was definitely the
highest drug use I've ever seen anywhere
it was so rampant uh it was just in my
face all the time I was a medic in the
Army so I got a lot of practice uh doing
IVs in the barracks and there was no
questions asked when my Aid back needed
to be replenished
um it was it's just known so but
America won't enforce these drug laws on
their own troops there's no enforcement
uh because they'd have to face the
embarrassment of a drug-addicted uh
troops and the hypocrisy of a government
that knows this situation and uh but
instead sends SWAT teams into uh regular
Americans homes to compensate drugs
uh so I just uh
on prohibition
somebody asked me to bring up this quote
from H.L Milken so five years of
Prohibition have had at least this one
benign effect they have completely
disposed of all the favorite arguments
of the prohibitionists none of the great
Boons and user effects that were to
follow the passage of the 18th Amendment
have come to pass
there is not less drunkenness in the
Republic but more
there's not less crime but more not less
insanity but more the cost of government
is not smaller but vastly greater
and respect for the law has not
increased but this minute diminished
and that is true I feel like the respect
for law in uh this country is is greatly
diminished because these arbitrary drug
laws in the arbitrary enforcement of
them
so there's tons and tons of arguments
against uh prohibition uh and just you
know some of them you know like when
drugs are legal uh police brief forces
police resources can be reduced and
yours to use towards combating uh real
crimes like theft assault and murder uh
I believe it's the reason why police are
against uh changes like this is because
you know it's going to reduce the
resources that are needed to for that
kind of thing so today the police are
Mill tries to fight this War on Drugs
the the actual 357 revolver cartridge
was developed uh so the police could
fight gangsters in the 1920s because
with the uh now they were using body
armor and uh you know car doors and
stuff like this for cover
uh instead of the uh 38 so and and that
that was in the 20s now Keena Hampshire
has uh what the city calls a ballistic
engineered armored response
counter-attack truck
um but most people just call it a tank
um so also it would reduce the harm
associated with drugs okay so the
criminalization drugs doesn't do
anything to stop the sale distribution
of drugs it just pushes the uh
this Market underground you know leading
drugs to be adultered and contaminated
with other
harmful substances all right so deleting
318b which this bill does will make the
drug sales more transparent to the end
user
um it reduced the number of people in
prison so legalization and drugs to
decrease the number of people being sent
to prison for drug offenses reducing the
strain on the prison system and reducing
the number of people who would be fired
from life from certain opportunities
because of their criminal record
uh so I urge the committee to take you
know very simple Common Sense approach
to this problem by deleting the
controlled Drug Act and making the OTP
motion uh on this bill
all right and I'll take any questions
represent Boulder
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
I understand that the chapter 318b
um includes rsas that give New Hampshire
entities the ability the sort of like
legal coverage to engage in activities
that violate federal law for example
naloxone being an over-the-counter
product in New Hampshire
um which is sort of In conflict with FDA
standards and DEA standards from
naloxone that's in 318b
the syringe program is part of 380b is
it your intent to repeal
um
laws that we have in New Hampshire that
give legal shelter to people trying to
engage in harm reduction
yeah so like 318b is extensive it covers
a lot of things like when you're talking
about so this bill it goes into effect
in 2025 and also establishes a study
committee so we can uh make legislation
to move that kind of stuff in other
places
yes Father
is it your thank you for taking my
follow-up question so is it your
understanding or expectation that
um after the repeal and and before the
passage of new legislation that for a
period of time it wouldn't be possible
for harm reduction efforts in New
Hampshire to operate with that legal
cover
so uh a matter of priorities uh if it
comes to using government resources for
harm reduction that would be preferable
to using them uh for criminalization uh
so if that was the Compromise then I
would I would be for uh using government
for harm reduction
representative Murphy
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question actually you probably just
to answer this a little bit but you had
said that this passage of this bill
would reduce harm and I just wondered if
you could explain a little bit more how
it would how that would
reduce harm thank you
well uh for one uh drugs are cut uh with
other substances because it's uh you
know uh this Market is unregulated
there's no one to check there's no way
to know right especially if you're just
an end user and then uh
like the drugs are like supercharged
they find out ways to make them more
powerful than they were otherwise
because because they're prohibited uh
when you're transporting them or
anything like this you know you want to
transport more uh like potent drugs uh
instead of something you don't need a
car full of something that's not as
potent you know because if it's illegal
you have to densify it if you will so
that's some of the things that increase
harm besides that
um
just you know the criminalization of it
makes it you know so that there's no
legal recourse in the in the way most
business is done so people have to
resort to uh violence and things like
this
to conduct their business like
representative Newman
yeah I just have a question about
line one in this bill that says
repeal RSA 318b relative to the control
Doug is repealed
so what happens when this Bill gets
caught that gets passed is that
automatically um
repealed by the passage of the
government when the governor were to
sign this and what date would that be
effective
yeah that's correct so uh if this passes
uh the drug the drug uh 318b isn't
deleted immediately but it will be uh
July 1st 2025 and
uh so that doesn't
thank you
representative breed
thank you for taking my question
um
if this bill if the controlled Drug Act
is repealed what would that look like
would you go to the grocery you know
would it be can you just go and buy any
of these controlled substances from your
pharmacist what does what would it look
like thank you
yeah uh so we'd expect that dangerous
substances like you know hard drugs and
stuff like this they would be illegal
you could sell them to the public
but uh it would be not publicly popular
to sell these things to children and we
feel like the market would would
regulate that kind of thing and not put
it in places where it would be
inappropriate
thank you
representative Pratt
is this similar to what they did in
Oregon
oh sorry I didn't hear you say that
again please
it's just similar what they did in
Oregon State
or on state legalized or decriminalized
all drugs is this what this is
I'm sorry I can't hear you
is this the same as decriminalizing
drugs as they did in Oregon State
this just deletes 318b
so it would make it like lots of things
that it's just not not regulated at all
right
apologize Mr chair didn't hear the end
of that
um my question would be uh you know when
we're talking about
um establishing a committee uh talks
about to study the statutory of policy
uh changes to state law necessary to
implement the repeal my concern is uh
about the regulation I mean you
literally just said no regulation you
you also had mentioned
um you know the the things that are put
into uh other drugs and and things will
be mixed in and people don't know
exactly what's in there and so my
question is you know
would the committee be also what would
what the committee is studying include
uh testing and analyzing and labeling so
that people actually do know what is in
their drugs and and regulation in that
way
uh you're asking uh how we would know
that the drugs are clean or whatever uh
without regulation yes yeah so uh the
market would regulate that just like ISO
9001 uh the way they regulate industry
and all these other organizations there
would be
um
you know independent uh organizations
that would vouch that you know they
would check out this these guys
producing this drug and they would put
out a report that says they're legit
um just the way a lot of things are
regulated in the market so in the way
the government would do it except we
don't we don't need
to extort the public to have these
checks we can just let the market Do It
um and there'd be demand for that kind
of thing
thank you for your testimony this
morning representative thank you the
chair recognizes Ms Bonnie Freeman of
the Shire Free Church
hello my name is Bonnie Freeman
um I just wanted to come and support
this bill
Terence McKenna wrote that unsrambled
rationalism male dominance and attention
to the visible surface of things had
rendered Society very very sick
as a progressive who believes humans
were put on this Earth to evolve and
create a better and better world for us
to live in I believe that the
government's hindering of human beings
exploring their own Consciousness
Consciousness which humans calling
themselves government have no right to
do in the first place is not only evil
but holding human beings back from our
potential
exploring different states of Mind helps
people to grow in their perspectives to
change
I agree with McKenna that our society
today is very sick and even sicker now
than it was when he died in the year
2000.
as of 2016 2.3 million people were
incarcerated in the United States
at a rate of 698 people per 100 000.
um that doesn't sound like a very
I mean it sounds like a sick Society to
me
and it's honestly uh barbaric
the fact that most of those people not
most of those people but any of those
people are in prison for uh
utilizing their right to put whatever
they want into their body and it is
right because they're not doing anything
wrong to anyone else
is disgusting to me
and no matter what you guys decide today
you won't be able to stop everyone in
New Hampshire from putting whatever
substances they want into their body
anyways
and that's all
thank you for sharing with us this
morning
is there anyone else who has not
testified in this bill that wishes to
and chair recognizes Mr Ian Freeman
uh good morning thank you for listening
today on this very important piece of
legislation I understand that for
decades now we've been arguing over
nibbling around the edges of the the War
on Drugs talking about ending
prohibition of cannabis that alone has
been controversial I expect this one
will be quite controversial as well but
the reality is and I don't think there's
any controversy that the War on Drugs
has failed
it has been failing from the very
beginning
it has cost trillions
of dollars it has cost thousands if not
hundreds of thousands of ruined lives
millions of people have been put behind
bars
who have never harmed another human
being they simply took a substance into
their body to change their state
it has never worked prohibition has
never succeeded all it has succeeded in
doing as Mr Santa nastasso pointed out
as creating a black market
and making the drugs even more dangerous
than they have ever been
now this isn't your fault this was done
before you guys came into office it was
done decades ago and it was done under
dishonesty and lies to make this War on
Drugs happen
it doesn't work
and we've seen people who are in the
business of fighting this war who have
said that there was recently a DEA agent
who was arrested for corruption of
course
and before he went to prison he spilled
the beans he said that everyone in the
DEA knows that the War on Drugs is a
failure they know it
they know they can't win this war
it's impossible and that's because
supply and demand cannot be defeated as
long as there is someone out there who
wants to use drugs there will be someone
who's willing to flaunt the law to make
the insane profits that they're able to
make because of the War on Drugs
that's where the money gets good because
it's illegal to sell these products it
becomes worth a lot more
so we would likely see the prices of
drugs come down we would see the quality
of the drugs go up we wouldn't see
adulterants being added to these drugs
which means that you would see fewer
overdose deaths we know there's a
problem with Heroin we know there's a
problem with with a lot of drugs people
being abusing these drugs
that's not a crime it shouldn't be a
crime to have a medical problem an
addiction and throwing someone into a
prison cell doesn't help them with that
addiction
so if we want if we really do care about
drug users and that is reportedly the
reason why the War on Drugs exists is to
supposedly help people
than if we really cared about them we
would pass this bill and end the war on
drugs and Lead the Way
in the United States
to do that because then those people
would actually be able to get the help
that they need we've seen it in places
like Portugal which has had
decriminalization of all drugs for a
very long time for about two decades
people aren't afraid to go and get help
whereas now they're afraid because they
think they're going to get turned in
and they'll have to go to prison
so if we really care about people this
is uh is the way to go yes people are
going to do drugs irresponsibly they
already do that
it's already illegal to get behind the
wheel of a car and drive under the
influence that is not being repealed
here
DUI would still be a crime
so this just looks at reality and it
says we're going to admit here in New
Hampshire that the War on Drugs has
failed we can admit our failure
and try to make it right thank you happy
to take questions
representative Peru
so you did talk about people getting
addicted and it's not their fault and
they shouldn't go to prison
but if we repeal all this
and correct me if I'm wrong it would
make it a lot easier
for a larger number of people to get
addicted because it would be handed to
them pretty much is that correct I don't
know if it would really be that easy I
mean anybody that wants drugs can get
them
it's you know you just have to know the
right people
you can get them online now too
yeah
I don't think they're threatening those
people with jail I'm just going to stop
them
it hasn't
thank you for your testimony
they're being no further testimony on
the bill I hereby close the public
hearing on HP 581 and the committee will
be in recess until 12 45.
request
foreign
for House Bill 473
relative to penalties for controlled
drug violations
and
oh boy
uh well I was looking for representative
Roy but he's not here
um
representative I'm going to slaughter
your last name
could you help me out
I
he's on here right
okay so hold on I signed from next bill
360.
my apologies I was we were we're working
so okay so is there somebody here is
there a co-sponsor here for represent
for Senate for House Bill 473
okay
good afternoon Madam chair I'm here to
introduce House Bill 473 FM well to the
penalties of controlled drug violations
and I'm sure there's people behind me
that can explain this better than I can
thank you representative
okay I can read Jonathan I apologize but
I cannot read this last name
all right you you're up
if you you could identify yourself
that'd be great
there we go I have a um
couple handouts uh would you like me to
bring those up right now
the handouts one is going to be my
written testimony the other is going to
be
detailing the schedule or the drug
schedule
representative if you could just please
identify yourself before you yes sir
actually you might not be represented in
my bed yes ma'am my name is Jonathan
Duchene
thank you for allowing me to speak on
behalf of the Manchester police
department and Chief alderberg and
opposition of house bill 473--fm
I work for the Manchester Police
Department as a detective in the special
enforcement division
I've been a police officer for nearly 20
years and within my current role for the
past eight years
I'm also a lifelong resident of the
State of New Hampshire
as a detective working in the special
enforcement division my primary function
is to identify problem locations in
subjects who are responsible for the
possession distribution of illegal
narcotics within the city
in addition to identifying these sources
I along with other members of the
detectives assigned to the special
enforcement division conduct routine
drug and addition interdiction stops
arrests and search warrants and arrest
warrants
we also cultivate informants who in turn
further investigations to locate the
source of these illegal narcotics and
conduct long-term investigations
when I started as a detective working
narcotics in Manchester in 2015 it was
at the beginning of the opioid epidemic
in the United States Manchester gained
National recognition not in a positive
way during this era as U.S news and
World Report listed in a June 20 2017
article identifying New Hampshire as
quote Ground Zero
for the opioid crisis further listening
that in 2015 two-thirds
of the state's drug deaths resulted from
Fentanyl
in 2016 ABC news also dedicated a 2020
episode with David Muir who came to New
Hampshire in Manchester highlighting the
current crisis within the state
I've been on countless arrests seizures
of all kinds of drugs to include but not
limited to heroin fentanyl cocaine crack
cocaine crystal meth and prescription
drugs these investigations during these
investigations it is becoming more and
more common that these seizures are tied
to violent crimes and deadly weapons
many of our investigations originate
from someone who commits a crime who is
going to provide information in exchange
for consideration on the on their charge
in turn we are able to expand and Branch
out our investigations
when I was being aware of house bill
473--fm
it concerned me greatly as I know the
negative effect it will have on our
state and local communities house bill
473-fn is seeking to reduce the penalty
for schedule one through four in
Narcotics from our class B felony to a
misdemeanor for offenses
this will inherently New
Hampshire law enforcement in our role of
enforcing prevention of serious
narcotics as those people would who
would normally be willing to provide
information will no longer do so as
there will be little deterrence
we need to look no further than the
state of Oregon which in 2020 shows a
similar path in decriminalizing serious
narcotics
an Associated Press article from 2021
outlined since decriminalization Oregon
Saw an increase of 20 percent in
overdose deaths
with a budget of 302 million dollars in
facilities used for treatment
furthermore out of the 16 000 people who
set access to services for the first
year of the decremental
decriminalization only
0.85 percent entered treatment so less
than one percent
given my years of experience as a police
officer and as a detective in their in
the narcotics unit
the knowledge I've gained supports at
these illegal drugs specifically those
designated schedule one through four
have a ripple effect caused by their
trafficking and use
I have seen firsthand that these drugs
have an addiction rate that is linked to
other crimes that occur such as but not
limited to burglaries thefts assaults
violent crimes Etc
and more often than not are the driving
Factor Behind These offenses in closing
it is my opinion supported by years of
being on the front lines in this
epidemic that house bill
473-ftn will have an adverse effect more
than its intended purpose
I ask that you find this bill in
expedient to legislate
I thank you again for your time and
consideration in this matter
respectfully detective Jonathan Duchene
Manchester Police Department special
enforcement division
thank you detective are there any
questions from the committee
yes ma'am representative Knoll
thank you and uh thank you for taking my
question
um you talked about
um you know Manchester being Ground Zero
I mean New Hampshire being Ground Zero
um I'm very familiar with um the
overdose crisis I actually lost my uh
children's father and fiance at the time
14 years ago uh Christmas Eve to
overdose so it's been a little over 14
years and over those 14 years I've seen
prevention enforcement through the
criminal justice system
not only in his case but also you know
just over time
increase and increase and yet the
problem has gotten worse and I'm just
curious you know more people die all the
time and so
um I wonder how you feel about this
approach
um and how successful it is
well first off
um I'm very sorry for your loss what I
can say given my experience is if we
reduce the penalty on this there's going
to be
a Floodgate Of the drugs entering in the
state even more so than there already is
and it's going to make our job
almost impossible to to do to try and
go after the suppliers and go after the
people that are affected essentially
Distributing poison out on our streets
and that's why I'm here today and that's
why I'm very concerned with this bill
father
you recognize a follow-up question
thank you and I I mean no disrespect I'm
not trying to criticize it all I I fully
believe that
um that the intention here is is very
pure and good
um my question is the the follow-up is
is one of the issues that you cited is
um the fact that Fentanyl and now other
drugs are are being found in substances
and they are much more powerful and and
harmful
um and I'm wondering you know
do you think it would make your job
easier and and be helpful to people who
are struggling with it to um to know
what's in their drugs and you know know
what's in their supply
um
I guess that's the essential question
what I can say is given my experience
people that do have an addiction or
people that are are dealing
unfortunately really
pay no attention to the potency in the
drug more or less they're looking for
the most potent drug that is out there
to give them a better High out there on
the street that's been my experience and
specifically dealing with fentanyl
thank you I appreciate you thank you
representative scitec
hi detector
question I have is this
uh misdemeanor Aid carries a year
in jail so the potential of that what
I'm wondering about it which is
significant for somebody that's using
not selling
where I'm going is this
have or does anyone have any real
statistics on just how
Superior Court sentences people are they
getting anything more than a year
wouldn't misdemeanors do the same
aggressive enforcement of misdemeanor do
the same thing how are felony bees
special felonies
what what what is their outcome
typically
do you see the area that I'm interested
in
uh yes sir I I hope I can try and answer
your question to the best of my ability
um
it's been my experience especially
dealing with serious narcotics such as
fentanyl crystal methamphetamine those
other driving Factor unfortunately what
is taking place on the streets in
Manchester right now and a lot of times
those narcotics are kind of go hand in
hand with um
people that carry weapons and commit
violent crimes and I'm sure many have
seen in the news a lot lately that
they're violent crimes do take place in
Manchester more than we would hope for
or want so there's definitely that
factor with tied to these uh to these
illegal drugs
representative wheeler thank you madam
chair I appreciate your concern about
people
and their addictions to opioids I'm
wondering do you think throwing someone
in prison would Aid or ail their
addiction
Chief aldenberg is also here from the
Manchester Police Department
for the record I'm a chief Alan
aldenberg chief of police the Manchester
Police Department so representative
you're asking
um
being in or out what would help their
addiction most
is that what you're saying well would
being in prison Aid their addiction
essentially would someone who's not
selling uh and has been addicted to
drugs with throwing them in prison well
I mean the theory of somebody's in
prison they shouldn't have access to
drugs right but are there drugs in the
criminal justice in the correction
system yes they're right but not to the
level that are on the streets
so I'm kind of is that is that your
point is that
yeah I just want to make sure I got it
right absolutely and I uh more wondering
about the environments in prison if
someone has is on the streets addicted
to drugs and that homeless person is
arrested and would would
have been having them be in prison uh be
conducive to them getting off the
addiction
well certainly if somebody's addicted to
drugs and they're still remaining on the
street their ability to remain addicted
is
exponentially more if they were in a
prison or in a jail
so I hope I'm answering your question
there so are people that are you know
people are not being detained for drug
offenses
um majority of them
I'm sure there's others in the room that
may disagree but people are being
arrested for first offense third offense
fifth offense for drug possession or
drug distribution and of being released
over and over and over and that's not
helping the addiction problem that's not
helping what we're dealing with is it is
imprisoned and putting people in prison
the answer to this problem I wouldn't
Advocate that I think that you know
along the lines of treatment
intervention education
whatever we can do along those lines is
just as important as the enforcement
angle right we're not going to enforce
that way out of this problem
are we going to get our way out of this
problem by putting everybody into jail
in a prison no I don't
um are people more apt to get the
treatment perhaps that they need inside
a facility and get into a program that's
more structured whether we have their
attention
I would say there's an argument in favor
of that
I'm glad to have a conversation with you
after sir absolutely representative
Newman
I have a question that's a little maybe
along the same lines it looks like from
my reading of the bill that the current
punishment is a class B felony
and then the bill reduces it to a
misdemeanor for the first offense
um and the second and the other
punishment is Class A going to a class B
felony
since the class A misdemeanor has the
possibility of a year in jail
why would that be an improvement to the
bill rather than going all the way to a
class B felony which is three to seven
years
and it may there may be something in
there in the court process where one or
the other gets prosecuted more often or
or leads the way to maybe
um
coming up with a plea deal or something
like that I'm just wondering why why go
all the way to a
just why not
um would it be helpful as if it was a
Class A misdemeanor
you're saying that
in your opinion and somebody's convicted
of first offense misdemean Class A that
they got to get that year in jail
I'm pretty confident that they're not
going to get that year in jail that's
the reality of our court system right
now
I have people that are
um
committing crimes over and over and over
and are not getting the appropriate
sentence that they should that's not my
my doing or my decision we put forward
cases but unfortunately what we live in
now is that people aren't getting the
appropriate sentences in some cases that
they deserve and that's why we have
these repeat offenders to the detector's
point if you make these misdemeanor
level offenses the the drug
organizations these cartel level
organizations are going to flood this
state
okay because they are more than they
already do
because they know that they are now
operating in a state with a penalty for
spreading this poison in our state and
killing people
um for those that are in possession of
it there are going to have minimal to no
ramifications
I can quite I
would be very
you know very confident saying that
people on a first offense
you know that becomes a misdemeanor
level conviction
they're not going to go to jail
I just know from experience I know from
how my court operates how Hillsborough
County operates
um they may go into drug court okay if
drug court was an effective mechanism
right now I can speak and tell you that
it's not
if drug court
was better in operating more efficiently
than maybe that's a better option for
those people to have that first offense
felony or misdemeanor
thank you
representative scitec I'd like to thank
you for appearing Chief the I want to
follow up on what I had asked before you
said very few
misdemeanors get actual jail time that's
the way our court system is I understand
that earlier today I said I'm a bail
commissioner I kind of have an idea of
what you're talking about
my question is this what happens in a
felony conviction class B felony
conviction what is the likely sentence
further experience first offense First
Defense yes
depends on a lot of things go into play
there the person's overall criminal
record
um if you take a case where it's a first
offense Class A and they have no other
criminal record I would say that the
likelihood of them going to prison is
probably relatively well they're
probably looking at some type of
extensive
probation
drug court some other residential
program is part of a plea deal
but he got there's a lot of a lot of
variables that go into determining
somebody's sentence when it gets to a
judge as you all know
further questions thank you we
appreciate your time thank you
representative Roy
thank you for taking my testimony I'm
representative Kerry Roy representing
Rockingham District 31 towns of
Deerfield Candia
Auburn and Chester have to get that
right they changed with the redistrict
um I apologize for not being here for
the opening of this unfortunately I
realized having the chair position
everybody wants to talk to you and I got
way laid six times on the way back here
um so with regard to this bill
I understand law enforcement's position
and I agree with them a lot that it's a
valuable tool
to have in your Arsenal to be able to
charge someone with a felony on the
first offense
I disagree with them and that's how we
should be operating our justice system
we should not be creating felons in my
opinion
out of so many people for first offense
on this and that the the drug
crime has not gone down with the
felonies
it stays the same it seems to really not
matter what it is but what does happen
is we've created a whole bunch of people
that were putting out of the labor pool
when you have a felony conviction
there's a whole slew of jobs you cannot
get
um and and it does we can discuss the
whys and hows but it does
disproportionately affect minority
communities
and these are the people who have the
lowest unemployment rates to begin with
the highest unemployment rates excuse me
I think that we need to look at a
different way to do this a different way
of interdicting drugs we need to give
the police the tools they needed to stop
the drugs coming into our communities
more than punishing the people who get
caught with with the first offense
amount and let's be clear as far as what
that means
you're still if the amount is correct
you're still going to get charged with
possession intent or with distribution
or with drug kingpin depending on the
amount of drugs you have we're talking
about simple possession
now I believe we need to tweak the
amounts on certain things like fentanyl
should be much smaller
but the other drugs you're talking about
a personal use amount of drugs not
enough to sell not enough to distribute
personal use
and there's a big difference in my
opinion someone who is using
they're hurting themselves but they're
not Distributing
and
a misdemeanor crime conviction is no
small thing there are there are
penalties there's jail time possibility
there's Financial possibilities it's
still a very serious thing to happen to
somebody
so I would ask the committee to consider
in way how the current system is working
if it's working and if it's not
is there a greater benefit in producing
less felons in making people have a
chance to go forward in society and
improve their lives or tagging them as
felons and limiting the amount of work
and future opportunities in their life
which already sets them down a path of
hopelessness
so that that's my testimony I'd be happy
to take questions
representative Gendron
the vice chair and thank you for taking
my question
I noticed that uh on the first offense
you're proposing a change at class B
felony to a misdemeanor and my question
to you is this misdemeanor a is uh
potential of jail time and the right to
council misdemeanor B has no right to
counsel and is fine only would you
would you
have any
thoughts on whether it should be a
misdemeanor A or B and why did you
choose just a misdemeanor
if I heard you correctly whether or not
I would be open to either level of
misdemeanor and and possibly because it
doesn't give a right to counsel is that
is that correct
yeah a misdemeanor a uh affords you a
right to counsel a misdemeanor B does
not
agreed but I don't think that charging
someone with a higher level offense just
so they can get right to counsel is
probably a a good policy I'm not I'm not
sure understandably that they they need
counsel regardless of the level but I
don't think that we can solve that by by
charging up just so they get counsel I
just I would worry about that
but as the father whether or not the
penalty is appropriate that's something
that we can discuss and I'd be happy to
discuss with everyone when we're
debating this issue in the executive
session
no
see no further questions thank you
representative Roy thank you
thank you Dan Hines
oh representative I'm sorry yeah that's
okay I don't think it's on here in my
defense
yeah I will fix my future
um thank you Dan Hines representing
um Hillsboro 2 kind of Bedford and
obviously support this bill and I don't
want to be redundant but I think people
are in agreement and a lot of people ask
well what's the penalty for this so my
way background criminal defense lawyer
have handled drug possession cases over
the years and so
unfortunately it's not very consistent
in my opinion throughout the state so
many County attorneys will routinely
drop these down to misdemeanors but
others will not at the end of the day if
someone has a simple possession of
cocaine that heroin any of these felony
type drugs they have no criminal record
nothing else I don't see even if they
went to a jury trial and were found
guilty I do not see a judge sentencing
that person in prison routinely people
get in my experience I think if there's
nothing else people get House of
Correction time which is jail which can
only be up to 12 months which would make
it a misdemeanor level penalty
and oftentimes that's all suspended if
it were a plea often there's conditions
with that so it could be to be on
probation or it could be drug counseling
things to that effect at the end of the
day people are not going to prison for
first offense possession charges um
unless they were sentenced on something
else like that or something like that
all this is doing with the making it a
felony is making them have a felon
criminal record what that is doing is
presenting that preventing them from
obtaining employment in the future I
think personally the best way to address
the drug problem is Rehabilitation I
think people use drugs fall into two
classes people who are addicted to it
and people who recreationally use it for
both of those people I think
Rehabilitation is still the best
approach but punishment just does not
work people are not being sent to prison
for up to seven years on these types of
charges so it's already not happening
um
I think the position that this would
invite drug cartels to the state is
borderline absurd I certainly don't
think it will happen
um because this is only applying to
people possessing because not applying
to people Distributing drug cartels
cannot come in if this bill were to take
laws and say Here Sell some drugs you'll
only have a mismir not going to happen
there's still going to be a facing
felony selling or distribution penalties
I do not think anyone who goes out
seeking for drugs in the back of their
mind goes well I don't want to do that
it's a felony but ah it's missed me let
me have some of that drugs it just
doesn't happen like that
uh in regards to difference between our
representative jamprin's question abris
b
um the reason I was supported being not
defined is most of our criminal code
doesn't Define things there are a few
exceptions so DWI First Defense is a
Class B the reason being as you point
out people don't get counsel
um some chart charges are specifically a
particularly if they have a penalty
associated with it with mandatory jail
time they would have to be but I think
leaving it just a blank misdemeanor that
leaves the prosecution discretion to
bring it as an ARB which I think makes
sense I don't think all drug charges are
the same so there's a difference between
someone who has I guess just
small amount of cocaine or heroin and
that's it versus someone who is doing
that coming thefts all types of other
things so I I think it should be up to
the prosecutor whether to bring it as an
A or B in that regard
um
I think there's any everything I'm happy
to take any questions
representative chandron
thank you and it's Unique that you're an
attorney that defends cases in this
matter so my question to you would be on
average how many of these cases that are
covered by this bill are actually
deferred to the drug court
so I don't know the answer that I know
we've been expanding the drug courts
over the years and I'm certainly
supportive of that do you think that is
one of the best ways to go about
addressing this issue and I don't know
if there's a uniform policy throughout
drug courts and counties of what happens
after the fact
um but they do it do it a little
differently so or I'm not sure if they
all do it exactly the same as well but
there are cases that just don't go to
drug courts so they do have I guess
typically requirements to get into that
court so if this fell outside of that
um I think
it's appropriate then for those offenses
to be misdemeanors
so you know further questions thank you
thank you
Frank knack
Madam chair members of the committee
thank you so much for the opportunity to
testify my name is Frank Knack I'm the
policy director with the ACLU of New
Hampshire and we are here in strong
support of hb473
so I want to talk at first about
um a couple of issues I think one we
talked that we heard a little bit about
the need to have prison as a punishment
and just to give some economics here it
costs about 64 000 a year to incarcerate
someone in our prison uh substantially
cheaper to actually engage in
evidence-based harm reduction programs
at the local level and fortunately there
are multiple bills before this committee
and this this body this session around
access to drug testing kits we already
have naloxone those are proven
evidence-based strategies if you really
care about saving lives and reducing
harm in our communities
um I think it's also really important to
point out you know when we think about
drug arrests we think about you know we
are going after dealers and that is just
fundamentally not the case here in New
Hampshire so again if in the fact sheet
I handed out we have the data to show
you we looked at FBI UCR data reports
that our state agencies provide to the
FBI
and out of the five three thousand five
hundred ninety two drug arrests in 2021
in New Hampshire 87 so 3150 were Premier
possession so the vast majority of
arrests happening in our state right now
are for possession level offenses
um in that possession level disparity is
actually increased so over the 10-year
period it was 80 so we're actually going
in the wrong direction we're arresting
more people for simple possession
um and not uh for distribution
um we also heard a little bit about the
enormous collateral consequences that
attach to a felony conviction and I just
quickly looked up so we have you know
all types of collateral consequences
um under our law some are mandatory some
are discretionary some are by defense
type so I just pulled mandatory
misdemeanor and mandatory felony so for
mandatory felony collateral consequences
under New Hampshire law that apply to
all aspects you know from education to
housing to employment there are 335
various collateral consequences that
attach to every felony conviction in New
Hampshire for a misdemeanor it's still
extremely high at 99 but substantially
fewer and so this notion that you know
going from a felony to a misdemeanor for
we're only talking about first time
possession here we're talking about one
narrow type of rest here it's still
substantial is we heard a yield a year
potentially in jail 99 mandatory
consequences that'll attach to that
person so it's still substantial
and there's also a huge racial disparity
that I think is really important to
point out so black people in New
Hampshire make up about 1.8 percent of
our population yet make up 6.5 percent
of all drug arrests so a staggering
racial disparity in our drug arrests and
so this this legislation will have you
know a really positive impact on
beginning to address those harms and I
think finally we heard this earlier
today from one testifier and we also
heard this a lot last year in this bill
which made it through the house last
year went over to the Senate we heard a
lot about we need to have harsh
punishment because harsh punishments are
what work and so you know we are now in
our 52nd year I think of the War on
Drugs back we started back in 1971 and I
think one thing is crystal clear you
know the notion that we can arrest our
way out of drug use is not supported by
reality but yet we continue to go down
that path and so I just want to one of
the reports I cite in here is from cute
charitable trust you know well respected
National learning that does research
and I'll just read read what they said
so they looked at available data from
federal and state law enforcement
Corrections and health agencies and
their analysis found no statistically
significant relationship between State
drug imprisonment rates and three
indicators of State drug problems
self-reported drug use drug overdose
overdose deaths and drug arrests the
findings
reinforce a large body of Prior research
that cast doubt on the theory that
stiffer prison terms deter drug misuse
distribution and Other Drug law
violations the evidence strongly
suggests that policy makers should
pursue alternative strategies that
research show work better and Cost Less
happy to answer any questions
representative Jennifer
thank you to the chair and thank you for
taking my question
I'm I find myself in a very unique
position where I represent the people of
Hampton which includes Hampton Beach
and I will tell you that um I believe
and and I don't know if you have
statistics to this effect because you
used all of yours from the FBI zcr but
do you have any idea of how many people
uh that go to our beaches from from uh
state to the South uh that are a
minority populations are arrested for
drug drug
uh possession
and and second part of that is
do you have any idea how many of those
people
yep
okay I'll let you answer that if you
have any idea I I know just state level
uh FBI ECR data the racial disparities
um in this case and also specific to
marijuana as well that I'd be happy to
discuss
and a follow-up you guys for follow-up
thank you for the recognition for the
follow-up and as a follow-up to that my
question is how many of these people
if it's
quoted in the UCR are arrested for
another offense in addition to
uh possession of drugs that may be a
violent crime
so my understanding is FBI UCR data is
primary primary offense data and so that
is the most serious offense so it would
have to be some lesser offense if there
were multiple charges
Senator wheeler
thank you madam chair thank you Frank
for taking my question
um were the arrests uh uh so out of the
3 592 arrests uh drug arrests were the
35 100 or 3150 that were for possession
where they just for possession or were
they including possession
so that was the primary offense uh so
there may have been other you know
lesser offenses included but that was
the primary attorney thank you
foreign
see no further questions thank you thank
you so much
Dr Hannah
closing I thought hello members of the
committee my name is Joe Hannan
um I've a pretty extensive background
working with the substance use Community
I've helped start some recovery
Community organizations uh harm
reduction groups syringe exchanges I was
involved in uh helping with the
legislation for in service programs
Narcan naloxone being legalized and a
lot of other different things I'm also
someone who's in long-term recovery for
over 31 years 32 years now I guess and
I've had a lot of experience with
individuals who have been incarcerated
and also people who have experienced the
harms of being incarcerated because of
their disease
uh there's a lot of things I could talk
about but I think one of the most
blaringly uh scary statistics that I
I've ever heard was
um the dangers of dying of an overdose
after being released from incarceration
within the first two weeks there was a
study in North Carolina at UNC back in
2018 it was published in the Journal of
Public Health
they had five researchers they had a
member from the North Carolina
Department of Public Health and also a
member from the Department of Safety
involved in the research project and
they they monitored the the overdose
deaths and people that were formally
incarcerated within the first two weeks
they found that the risk of dying of an
overdose in the first two weeks of being
released was 40 times higher than the
general population for all substances
when looking at heroin use only which
was also also include Fentanyl
that that same number jumped to 74 times
more likely to die of an overdose after
being released so we're arresting people
for their own safety and for Public
Safety but then when we release them
they're way more likely to die of an
overdose after that incarceration
there's other studies that looked at uh
being released and it can also apply to
short-term
mental health holds or even short-term
rehabs for a week or two in a detox and
then they kick someone on the streets
they can't get into a treatment program
so if someone is not being able to get
their substances which is not completely
impossible in jail I hear countless
stories I know firsthand accounts of
people who told me they have no problem
getting drugs in jail it might be a
little more of a an effort but it's not
a problem for people that really need to
do that really need to get them but for
some that don't they go through serious
withdrawal they're not giving medical
assisted treatment and they're sick
there they feel like they're going to
die it's one of the most horrible things
in the planet you can think of some
people might say oh they deserve it they
were doing drugs no one deserves to feel
like that
um and then when they get out their
their tolerance may be lower
uh they might not know what substances
they're getting because drugs are not
regulated we don't know what's in
something that's on the street so if
someone goes to a different dealer
because the person they were with might
have got arrested with them they have to
go to a new supplier they don't know
what's in it they can't go to Consumer
Protection to say that guy didn't give
me the same fentanyl I got last time so
they get something that may be stronger
or weaker if it's weaker they can't
complain if it's stronger they may
overdose and die
when we arrest someone
they're more likely to be unemployed who
lose their job if they had one and there
is a myth that people that do drugs
don't have jobs there were statistic
years ago I was reading that 74 of all
people who do heroin have one thing in
common that they either have a full or
part-time job
it it's hard to believe but it is true I
do uh syringe exchange Outreach on a
weekly basis in this in the state for
about five six years now and I see
people all the time they they pull up or
they come on their bicycles and some
people uh we tried to do it earlier in
the day but we have to do it later at
night because people work there are
people that work
um but if they get arrested they lose
their job and I hear this story I don't
think a month goes by where I don't hear
someone saying I had a job but I got
fired because I got arrested and even if
it was for a two or three day hold over
the weekend even if it was a misdemeanor
if they lose their job that person is
more likely to be unhoused not only
unemployed but unhoused and then less
likely to be able to have access to
treatment or any kind of uh help
whatsoever in the future when someone's
living in a tent in the woods because
they lost their job because they were
arrested for their own good what good is
that doing in society what is what is
the benefit of Public Health there is
none
um
so I mean I could I could keep going but
I think you kind of get the gist of it
I'd be happy to answer any questions and
I I beg you to please at the very least
pass this bill I think it should be uh
more but this is an excellent start and
I commend everyone for uh listening and
for the people who spoke in paper
yes I'm sorry they call it yeah
representative Noel sorry
um I I thank you first of all for taking
my question
um and thank you for um your service to
people in New Hampshire dealing with
substance use
um sounds like you've done some amazing
things in the harm reduction realm and I
appreciate that
um I was wondering if in your
um vast experience of working with
people who are struggling with that
um you know you talked about uh the
increase in the likelihood of overdose
death when someone uh is incarcerated
and then they're released and uh I'm
wondering you know I have my own
experience that I can put this into
because that's just anecdotal I'm
wondering if in your experience with a
lot more people how the threat of
incarceration impacts people's use
how the threat of incarceration well it
the the fact that something is illegal
in the first place drives drug use not
just underground but in into the shadows
and I mean that not just literally
figuratively literally uh you know
people will use behind a dumpster and a
dark alley but in a bush somewhere
they're more likely if they're using
injection drugs they're more likely to
have a mistake they might not hit the
vein they're trying to do it's more
dangerous people with money you know I
mean Keith Richards went all those years
and he's still alive somehow good for
him but you know he was able to do it a
nice hotel or in his big mansion
somewhere we don't really think about
not having the ability and the means to
to use safely and not even just illicit
substances if you are someone who's
diabetic and you have to keep doing
blood checks and checking your finger
sticks all the time and you can't wash
your hands and they're dirty you're
going to get an infection you're more
likely to have uh serious issues and I
was a foot and ankle surgeon for many
years I didn't see a lot of people uh
you know injecting in their feet but it
was definitely something that happened
and if someone is homeless or unable to
bathe on a regular basis and they don't
have a you know hot hot and cold water
or anyone water they are going to lose a
limb I've had to amputate feet and you
know people below the knee because they
had serious infections from shooting up
between their toes because they wanted
to hide their track marks or they just
ran out of veins somewhere else because
they kept having to rush and do
something very quickly so I'm not you
know I don't want to I'm not I don't
necessarily condone someone doing
something people make their own
decisions but I think it's very
important we do as much as we can to
remove the barriers to dangerous use to
it's it's already one thing to be taking
fentanyl or heroin it's another to have
policies in place for decades that make
it more dangerous and more harmful to
everybody and it's not just the people
that are getting these injuries and
these infections and losing their jobs
it's the healthcare workers and the and
the First Responders the police and the
EMTs who have to deal with this on a
regular basis a week doesn't go by where
I don't see a very serious infection
where I have to beg the person to go to
the hospital and it's it's a very hard
conversation to have they're afraid to
go to the hospital
uh either because of arrests or
mistreatment and it's not most providers
we have great treatment my wife was an
ER DOC for about 30 years
um you know it's it's very difficult
from that perspective even to see that
on a day-to-day basis when it can be
prevented we can have safer more Humane
policies in place that that prevent this
tragic loss of uh Health life and just
threats to Public Safety in general
thank you
thank you doctor thank you
is there anybody that is here that
wishes to testify that has not turned in
a pink card
so you know we will close the what will
you have do you want to testify
good afternoon for the record my name is
Heather Marie Brown I originally had not
planned on testifying on this bill
because I do think it is time that we
change penalties around how we handle
control substances in the state of New
Hampshire but I would also like to
remind the committee that as of right
now cannabis is still considered a
controlled drug and is still classified
as a level one controlled drug even in
the state and we do have a decrim
program we do have therapeutic cannabis
and I found it very difficult to
determine how this particular bill
um would possibly impact
cannabis in any way shape or form so I
would definitely ask the committee to
take a long hard look into that because
I can hear through testimony that the
intent of this bill is in relevance to
opioids and other narcotics but it is
not expressed in the bill language
itself and at this point in time no one
should be charged with a felony in
regards to cannabis for anything whether
they're a patient or they're a personal
user or anything like that so
I do agree with the need for change but
I do request that the committee take a
long hard look at how this particular
bill could possibly interact or
interfere with anything that's in place
or will be coming in place in regards to
cannabis or the therapeutic cannabis
program thank you very very much
a question
all right this time we will close the
public hearing for house bill 473.
at this time I'll open the public
hearing on HB
360.
introduce
to representative
Paul is off
spill
Mr chair
members of committee my name is of
representing Mary Martin
I'm here to
present Bill 360 FN enact legalizing
cannabis for persons 21 years of age or
older
I believe it's logical Next Step you
know that we need to take uh previously
we decriminalized
certain substances and brings reduced
medical marijuana
and we saw no negative effects after
those steps were intellect used
uh uh in a position to this bill
uh you will you you saw you will see
some additional statistics and I want
you that some of the statistics might be
inaccurate for example if we if a state
that uh legalized cannabis
does more testing that it might appear
that
marijuana can lead to more accidents on
the road
but we know that many users of such
substances they
tend to stay home or drive slower so
I run your
about those statistics and as you heard
before earned today Glock 4 has failed
and the prohibition has failed and
yeah New Hampshire is selling alcohol in
liquor stores
and it's a fact that alcohol is more
dangerous substance than what you can
find in cannabis
and two points why this bill needs to be
why we need that now
we are currently in Merrimack County and
in melanoma County we just don't have
staff for our jails here and certain
staff shortages you will see in other
countries around the state and currently
it's elevated by
we don't have as many convicts due to
Bell reform and as the circumstances but
as some of the steps of well reform are
about to be reversed and with
current
economic recession
leading to more crimes we will just have
not enough resources and the same with
police resources I represent towns that
are bordering Manchester New Hampshire
and you might have heard about
crime level in Manchester and from my
experience I might tell you
speaking with different Manchester
residents it's pretty common that police
doesn't have enough resources to
investigate property crime when there's
an actual victim when the vehicle was
damaged or stolen
and many Manchester residents wouldn't
even go to police if
if the bicycle stolen or something like
that because they know that it won't be
properly investigated and we our laws
direct police to investigate drug crimes
including people who smoke or sell weed
so as a legislative body it's up to us
to set up priorities trade for police to
help them to prioritize investigating
when there's an actual victims and
property crimes and last point you might
have heard about marijuana laced with
fentanyl it's something recent and why
it's happening the only reason why it's
happening it's because cannabis is not
legalized so when it's illegal
there's a no way for buyers to know its
quality
to set up some
process to verify
the legitimacy of a person who they
buying from so
actual lives are on the line because
those opiates can kill people and they
do kill people in in this country
thank you
represent Sally
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um so if I understand correctly this
legalizes cannabis completely Lee and
has no method in it for verifying that
what people have is pure and clean is
that correct
could you repeat the last sentence no
message to verify what so I'm just
trying to understand your bill is to
completely legalize cannabis but there's
no method for regulating the sale or
distribution or ensuring that it's not
leased
correct but when it's legal it's a salt
through
legal stories and then we have
all the safeguards
established by free market but also by
customer protection laws and knowing who
is your seller
thank you pure testimony thank you
the chair recognized Dr hin
uh thank you members of the committee I
want to introduce myself again it's not
been that long
um I don't want to speak too long on
this I make myself available to answer
any questions but I do like to um just
mention one little one or two little
things one uh we've heard a lot of
testimony in Prior cannabis bills and
legislation about uh access for youth
this is obviously for adults this does
not pertain to Children especially or
people under 21 who are also adults
um the other the other thing is you hear
a lot about uh talks about gateway drugs
and you know it's one thing leads to
another uh you know as someone who has
uh you know a youthful colorful youth
history himself I can tell you uh
personally and through a lot of
experience talking to other individuals
and research and different studies out
there that there is a much higher
likelihood of someone getting more
illicit substances on the illicit Market
more dangerous drugs like fentanyl
heroin methamphetamines if they're
buying something that is already on the
illicit Market that is a lower level
drug considered a lower dangerous
rock-like cannabis so you know most
teenagers are not going into a liquor
store and buying fentanyl they're not
going into a bar they're not going into
a cannabis store in Maine Vermont or
Massachusetts they're they're usually
buying it on the street and if we can
get rid of that we can actually make a
giant step in preventing uh underage use
of some of these substances
be happy to take any questions
representative wheeler sorry Mr chairman
I thank you for letting me take this
question
is it easy to get marijuana at a store
in Massachusetts or Vermont the states
where it's legal I haven't done it so I
don't know personally how easy it is but
I know people just drive across the
border they buy it and we've heard
testimony and I think yesterday we heard
something in Commerce about another bill
that was testifying there I don't talk
don't talk about this bill but
um there were several at least one or
two people testified about more cars
with New Hampshire plates in the parking
lot right over the Border in Maine and
Massachusetts and uh I know that's
that's you know from from people telling
me that they've done it to uh you know
hearing testimony it's definitely
happening it's not hard to do uh I'm
trying to find the statistics but
someone told me that how many that most
of the New Hampshire population up here
the percentage it's a very large
percentage within 45 minutes of a
dispensary in another state so they're
driving there they're getting it the
other thing is uh I've heard a lot of
complaints from law enforcement about
you know well there there are people we
don't have a way to test for it they're
on the roads they're driving they're
driving now and they're driving further
and longer because they have to go
somewhere else to get it because it's
not legal here so if you want to have
less people under the influence on the
roads
make it local I mean if it's if someone
has to go and get it usually responsible
people would wait till they get home
I'd like to think that was that's the
rule but it may not happen it's more
likely to be a problem if people have to
go further
thank you
representative Newell
um I'm curious uh since you're you seem
to be familiar with the subject rather
than a gateway drug to to use of other
more serious drugs one of the things
I've been reading about lately is its
therapeutic value in helping people uh
struggle with struggling with substance
use and I'm curious if you have
um if you have any knowledge on that and
if you could speak to it yes there's for
for many decades in this in this country
and around the world the the standard of
treatment for substance use was well
just don't do it you know we can't have
anybody doing anything just if you're
doing it you're not in recovery and uh
when I came around in 1991 that was the
school of thought you just don't do it
and I haven't since but there are a lot
of people who uh you know there's
there's a Continuum of of use from
casual to chaotic use and people fall
all along that Continuum of usage if
there's a way to get someone from very
chaotic use it's very harmful to get it
to more moderate or even occasional use
that's infinitely better than not doing
anything and staying a catech use and if
we force people to just be abstinent all
the time it's a nice goal but it's not
realistic we live in the real world and
I think that having options available
may not be the ideal for everybody but I
think it is an absolute necessity to
have it as an as an option available
years ago I was invited to Hempfest and
I was like well you know I was a State
Rep I was you know I think I knew I had
like 25 years in recovery I'm like I
appreciate the offer I'm okay I'm in
recovery and he looked at me goes so am
I I'm like what are you talking about
and he told me you know he used to do
this and like okay and crack and lost
his family all this stuff and now he has
all that back he smokes pot smokes
cannabis but he's got all those other
things and that is not just a one-off
situation I've heard countless
situations like that it's not my
preferred method of treatment but if it
works for somebody who am I to say that
they're living a better life is not
right for them and it does work for a
lot of people
thank you for your testimony
is there anyone else wishing to testify
this bill was not supported a car
um if it's all right I would just like
to add a little bit to what he was
saying
and now recognize Mr Freeman
uh so yeah I really appreciate this bill
and thank you all for uh for listening
to it
there's obviously a lot of legislation
that proposes to change the laws on
cannabis I appreciate the ones that
don't involve a bunch of regulations and
taxes and hoops and applications and
fees this is a plant it should be
treated like a plant meaning that the
government should stay out of it
somebody mentioned one of the Reps in
their questions mentioned lacing
cannabis as someone who has been
involved in the purchase of cannabis
over many years I have never come across
anything that would have been advertised
or not advertised as laced cannabis even
illegal drug dealers have zero incentive
to lace cannabis because it simply would
raise the cost of selling the Cannabis
there's no reason for that and there's
certainly no reason for a legitimate
Marketplace for you know a corner store
or a grocery store to you know deal with
lace to Canada so we certainly would not
we don't see it in the black market
today we certainly would not see that in
a in a legal Market the bill is you know
it's a complicated statute so there's a
lot of changes that it proposes and
maybe I'm missing it but on page two
section or I guess just after line 10 it
proposes to amend the RSA to strike
marijuana from some of the penalty
sections specifically section
IB and I C which deals with marijuana in
a quantity of five pounds or more or
marijuana in a quantity of five grams or
more but it doesn't seem to deal with
five grams or less or three quarters of
an ounce or less maybe that's somewhere
else that I just haven't seen it but
that's that's what comes after those two
so we're striking those two it would
seem we should strike the people who
have it for sale for less than three
quarters of an ounce as well again this
this does get us closer to treating
marijuana as the plant that it is and so
I support it thank you happy to take any
questions
thank you thank you
ma'am did you wish to test
thank you filling out the card we need
to for records
I I just wanted to add a little bit more
information to the question that
representative Newell had
um asked I believe it was uh in the
therapeutic cannabis program one of the
things that the medical oversight board
is working on is actually collecting
data that can be used for educational
and informative purposes we are seeing
very significant numbers so far that you
know we're not prepared to give out a
this is this percentage at the moment
but we are seeing significant numbers on
individuals being able to decrease
opioid use and the use of other hard
narcotics from their system
um and I personally myself have had that
experience I've been a therapeutic
cannabis user long before therapeutic
cannabis was legal in the state of New
Hampshire and had it not been for my
ability to use cannabis therapeutically
I do not believe that I would be
standing here today to talk to any of
you
I would probably if not be dead I would
be incarcerated
so I did want to throw that little
tidbit in there because I I think it is
important to know that you know no
matter how we choose to go forward with
legalization that there are positive
impacts in that individuals are allowed
to be and create a positive position for
themselves within society that does not
have to involve a lengthy criminal
background
thank you for everything
yeah
are you wishing to testify on the skill
Circle
the chair recognizes representative
bogert
good afternoon Mr chairman
fellow legislators
I'm not going to talk about statistics
or or how good bad or indifference
anything is
what I'd like to talk about is some
common sense okay we live in the Live
Free or Die State and a lot of the
problems with uh making pot illegal
is the fact it doesn't make any common
sense
some people say well it's a lead on drug
that lead you on to Other Drugs
well
one has to ask themselves
is that really true
okay now let's think about alcohol
is illegal
drug
okay
does it lead to alcoholism
yeah some people become alcoholics
but a greater majority of the people do
not
so it's called self-constraint
self-control and and being able to do
and enjoy it the way one does in their
own home
let's look at cigarettes
cigarettes we know for a fact kill
people
okay I don't need to quote the numbers
that everybody knows them okay you smoke
a greater majority of you going to die
from something from the cigarette
okay do we regulate it
I think we only say you got to be 21 to
buy it and then other than that you do
what you want
okay you might regulate where it is but
for a non-smoker I'm a non-smoker
I still have to put up with the smells
and stuff and the cigarette butts and
everything else but that's okay
that's the choice people get to make
living in a state it's called Live Free
or Die
so pot
candidates or however Which Way formed
you would like it
if enjoyed in the right way at your home
being 21 years of age
that why wouldn't you be able to enjoy
it
yeah I don't think anybody's ever heard
of a violent crying
coming out of someone who smoked a joint
except maybe to a Dorito bag or
something they might have got a little
vicious with but if you had to look at
it
how many people drunk has caused
problems that had too much alcohol
you've seen more people incarcerated
being drunk
causing trouble
real trouble
then you have for smoking a joint
okay
cigarettes
go back to that one
if you took a smoker
let's say they smoke a pack or two a day
and you put them in a situation where
they cannot have a cigarette
you've watched them
they become antsy they've become
irritable they become
outright I need to move out and have my
cigarette
okay
I have not seen anybody I you know yeah
you can tell I've been around a few
years
and I've never seen anybody go
I need to go have a joint
you know they go home they enjoy
themselves they listen to music they
watch hopefully not the news
and they relax
if you're looking around the states that
are around us we're the island
within everybody else moving on
they have more live free
than we do
okay and the other problem it creates is
as a resident of New Hampshire if you
cross the state line you're now breaking
another law if you go and get your pot
and bring it over to State Line you
bring break another laws
so does that really make sense to
criminalize people
for something
that if you go back to the history of it
shouldn't have never been illegalized
anyway
it was brought on by a rope company
because the plant was used for rope
and then the alcohol business got on
board because it was a cheaper way
for people that enjoy themselves than it
was for being having to go booze and
so
it's common sense
we're continually taking our youth
and I I Fair say most of you in here
have had a youth where you've sat and
done something
questionable and you had to question
yourself later in life
was that stupid I don't know
it's part of what makes you you
know so
the legalization of this is only the
next step of the evolution of our
society
you know
you can look at the numbers for alcohol
the cells in New Hampshire are going
down
why
who knows you would expect it to be at
least flatter going up but
it's not
so our people to find another way to
enjoy themselves
if people are allowed to live their
lives responsibly
people will
responsibly live their lives
the greater majority
and I I can't speak for the less than
because that's the problem in society
not everybody
is able to that's why you have
alcoholism
it's a smaller percent not everybody
enjoys a scotch when they go home or a
cold beer are they alcoholics no
so if someone goes home and enjoys
an edible or whatever it is they call
those things
and doesn't do anything else
what harm is it
I would say Common Sense would say none
you're tying up all your public service
forces tracking down people making
criminals
out of people who are doing nothing but
exercising their right to live free in
their home and enjoy
thank you
representative
so some excuse me
okay
sorry
so with alcohol there's a way to tell if
you're over the limit and
unable to drive is there a test for
marijuana or cannabis
my understanding currently there is not
a test but they are already looking at
it there were some promising stuff
coming out of Canada
for testing of that
but currently I believe there is no way
for testing of it
I'm good
thank you
representative silly
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question representative
um we heard this morning we heard HB 643
which was also about legalizing
marijuana but it was also in favor of
creating State stores for the sale of it
that would then be regulated much the
way that New Hampshire regulates alcohol
sales
I'm curious in your opinion whether you
think just completely decriminalizing it
so anyone can
grow it sell it distribute it without
any regulation is the better choice or
whether you think having some form of
structure to ensure the safety and
purity of the product is better
well
thank you for your question
that's a double-edged sword
as one might say because you're getting
rid of regulations and
creating regulations I do believe a
Gentleman Just earlier
indicated it's a plan so how do you
regulate someone growing something in
their house
okay are they doing something wrong if
they grew a tomato plant in their house
would anybody care
as long as they're not selling Tomatoes
unless there are farmer or something
so I would look at it this way if you
want to regulate it and put it in the
store so that you can see it
you can look at it as a cell in a bottle
of wine you could look at that as
selling beer you sell beer and wine
with the regulations there set forth in
in all the stores
so you sell we contain the liquor to the
liquor stores
all right so if you wanted to make it a
little room off the decide to the liquor
store I don't think anybody cares
it might be financially beneficial to do
it that way for the state because then
they can tax it and maybe make up for
some of the revenue loss that we're
starting to see as as as
people's choices are starting to change
and how they live their lives and stuff
so you know that's a way of creating
some Revenue if someone chooses but I
think you're going to uh
you're going to find people are going to
want to probably grow their own for our
own their own plant and stuff
um so you can look at that as someone
making a brewery they make uh what is a
hundred gallons a year or something I'm
not quite sure but there's some similar
type regulations for that
unfortunately I did not get an
opportunity to hear the bill because I
was across the street
in another session but uh
and I haven't fully read this one and I
do apologize for that but I did want to
make the point that there's a point in
time
that we just got to start moving forward
okay the workforce we see our
unemployment is 2.6 percent
okay
I used to be in retail in trying to get
someone with a background check once
you've gotten arrested for something
silly you can't get a job
so now you're regulated to be in
dishwashers and whatnot and what kind of
contribution
is that
to society or to your own family you can
okay and all they're doing is doing
something they feel is their personal
right to doing their home I'm not
excusing
smoking in your car driving down the
road by no means am I saying that
because once again the greater greater
majority is not there to do that
but if we looked at it as drinking
we read the newspaper every day it don't
need statistics the newspaper spells it
out in the arrest log how many people
are arrested for drinking and driving
okay
how many people have you seen that have
been arrested for something else
not as many I'm sure there are some not
going to say there's none
but once again
as we grow we got to start taking the
baby steps to get there
did that help you with that question
thank you
thank you for your testimony
and with that I'm going to close the
public hearing on hb3
360.
and open the public hearing on hb3
no actually an online
I got 10 minutes we'll be in recess
until 2 15.
foreign
to do the team
stretch
foreign
but in this type of case the lieutenant
says you know maybe we should refer it
to the police department I says no you
know but when the police officer did
show up I explained to him what we had
discovered and he says appreciate it and
you know chose not to
react to it but however common state law
says
technically it is against the law to
have immature plants I mean we did make
the law to says you can have up to three
quarters of an ounce but to grow it
it is not current so this will allow the
consumer or the person for every
particular reason the people with
glaucoma other things you know my bones
are aching myself and I finally Traverse
into being an old man but I will not
admit it you know because I don't act it
but the thing is for those people that
would want it for medicinal purposes
this allows them to grow on their own
and I come from Nashua and I think that
representative Kathryn can testify and
for those of us who live close to the
borders
that in Nashville and one does not have
to go very very far to pick up cannabis
you know you just go over the line into
things well it doesn't seem to be any
you know on gods or people at the border
or anything else like that so it's more
like a choice I think this is a wise
decision it's a small amount I think it
encompasses something like uh only three
immature plants and I think it's well
worth to try to see
worth having it and see if it fits
within the needs of the community and
for that I'll end it at that and
available for any of your questions
you guys are good thank you very much
she recognizes Frank knack
I don't think he's in here oh there he
is
that on sorry Mr chairman members of the
committee thank you so much for the
opportunity to testify my name is Frank
cunack I'm policy director with the ACLU
of New Hampshire and we're here in
strong support of HB 344.
um our support for marijuana
legalization in this bill in particular
is really through two lenses one is harm
reduction one is racial Justice
and starting with the racial Justice
lens so marijuana is the quintessential
issue to kind of look at race
disparities because we know from
substantial research that black people
and white people use marijuana up to the
same rates and so we can have Apples to
Apples comparison about what what's
happening underground in our communities
and
nationally so ACLU has done a number of
studies on this National looking at FBI
UCR data so this is official data given
to the FBI that we've analyzed and so
nationally black people are 3.6 times
more likely to be arrested for marijuana
possessions than white people in New
Hampshire it is substantially higher 4.6
times more likely to be arrested for
marijuana possessions than white people
um so this is from a kind of a
quintessential race disparity issue and
when you think about it in the kind of
collateral harms and how those impact
commercial wealth provide this is a
great opportunity for us to start to
repair the historical Harms
um that our history has had
um particularly in black and brown
community members
I think it's really also important from
a harm reduction lens to look at this
issue so when we passed uh
decriminalization a few years back you
know there's this thought process that
no one is going to jail for marijuana
anymore and while there be well there
may be very few people going to jail for
marijuana people can still get arrested
for marijuana possession and people
still are getting arrested for marijuana
possession so again looking at FBI UCR
data cited in our fact sheet over 1100
people were arrested for a simple
possession of marijuana last year alone
in New Hampshire and so as we talked
about earlier with collateral
consequences even a misdemeanor
Marijuana arrest has severe cuddle
consequences including 99 mandatory
collateral consequences that attach to
it and so it impacts you know your
ability to get housing to get employment
Etc and it's something that's unhelpful
in Ruins lives and also I'd like to talk
about a few of the the concerns we've
heard raised from from others currently
opposed to this effort and so there's
been a lot of talk about how marijuana
legalization has somehow increased youth
use in states where it is legalized and
so again I think it's really important
to look at what study academic
peer-reviewed Studies have found so this
is a study from the Journal of the
American Medical Association looking at
youth use in states that have legalized
and so here according to that study
recreational marijuana laws were
associated with an eight percent
decrease in the odds of marijuana use
and a nine percent decrease in the odds
of frequent marijuana use by youth and
so this tracks with other research that
has shown that there's been no uptick in
marijuana use
um uh among youth in states that have
legalized another issue is traffic
fatalities and so again looking at the
research from other states there has
been quote little to no effect unquote
on traffic fatalities and accidents in
other states
we've also heard about the opioid crisis
which is a very real problem as we
talked about in the last bill there are
a few bills ago
we have really good Solutions in this
committee this year and in this body
this year around drug testing kits uh
but evidence suggests that marijuana
legalization is connected with reduction
in opioid related deaths and so this
again is a tool for addressing as we
heard I think in earlier testimony it is
an alternative uh to reducing opioid
harm in our communities
um and finally
um you know there's been a there's been
a lot of talk
um of crime and how legalizing marijuana
in New Hampshire would lead to an uptick
in crime
and so again looking at the facts which
we think are important we heard
testimony from the Chiefs last year that
when marijuana legalization began in
Massachusetts and then you know went on
to Maine and Vermont that we had a
spillover affecting crime in New
Hampshire so again we have the benefit
of actually going through the data and
seeing what's actually happening and so
we did we looked at what happened and
then we looked at um State Department of
Safety crime stats between 2006 16 which
is the year Maine legalized in 2021
which is the most current year available
of full data crime is done 26 in New
Hampshire during that time and so this
notion that there's been spillover crime
again is not you know based in any
reality or based in any data
um happy to answer any questions and
really encourage your support thank you
represent men
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question you spoke
specifically about youth use and I don't
know unless I'm reading this wrong
this bill would essentially make it will
decriminalize the use of marijuana for
those under the age of 21 and for those
that want to reference it it's on page
three
line 20-25
where it makes it a violation for those
under 21 to normally possess three
quarters of an ounce I just wanted to
know what your position was on that
so it is still a violation and again
looking at the stats from states that
have gone from legalization we have not
seen an uptick so again this is where
it's really important from our
perspective that we engage in robust
public education because we're not here
saying that marijuana use is harmless
it's not but criminalizing marijuana use
which is what we're currently doing and
giving people criminal records and you
know putting them putting all these
unnecessary hurdles in front of people
is problematic and so we would
absolutely support robust public
education efforts not only for marijuana
but for all drugs and to move towards a
harm reduction lens approach to to
substance use
represent Boulder
thank you thank you for taking my
question
either I misunderstood you or maybe you
misspoke and I was hoping you could
speak to it again what were you saying
was the difference between
pre-2016 and post 2016 and I think you
said that's when we legalized but that's
when we decriminalize do I have that
right oh sorry I was talking about I
think that was in the context of arrest
and spillover crime and so there was
testimony from the Chiefs last session
that when um when States our neighboring
states began to legalize we faced
spillover crime in New Hampshire and
they used that as an indicator to say
that if New Hampshire followed suit we
would again see an uptick in crime and
so we look at the data from 2016 which
was the year the first legalization
state among our borders which was made I
believe and then through 2021 so I think
it was Vermont uh Maine Vermont in
Massachusetts I think for like 2016 2017
2018 ish and crime is down 26
um in in New Hampshire during that time
and so this notion that there was
spillover crime is just not backed by
any actual facts
if you have the information if not if
you could get it what about
Massachusetts since they legalized
what's their crime stats like I'd be
happy to pull that incidentally I
appreciate it thank you absolutely
representative salic
thank you for taking
sorry we're sharing a mic so
um I'm going to ask you a similar
question I asked one of the previous
speakers
regardless of what method the state uses
ultimately whether it's this year in the
future to decriminalize marijuana
um because clearly we're going to
eventually get there do you believe that
it should have regulations or just be as
free as one of the previous speakers
said as grown tomatoes which are
actually regulated
from our perspective hb6 I believe it's
hb639 which was heard in Commerce
yesterday is the ideal Bill to move
through this legislature that is a bill
and I'm not sure how much I've been
talking
it's okay if I just say a few sentences
um that is a bill that is um
co-sponsored by or is private sponsored
by uh leader Osborne and co-sponsored by
minority leader Wilhelm and reflects the
consensus of a broad diverse Coalition
of Advocates and stakeholders who have
come together over the past seven or
eight months it includes robust testing
it includes robust youth protections
um the the limits are in terms of
possession amounts are hired includes
annulments to start to prepare the Lost
harm the past harms from prohibition so
that is our ideal Bill and IT addresses
all those issues including advertising
to youth safe packaging Etc
thank you for your testimony thank you
so much
the chair recognizes Matt Simon
thank you Mr chairman you don't hear me
all right
for the record my name is Matt Simon I
work for Prime alternative treatment
centers of New Hampshire they're a
non-profit therapeutic cannabis
alternative treatment center
dispensaries and Merrimack and
Chichester a cultivation facility in
Peterborough we have about 55
employees and our focus is entirely on
serving great patients who are
registered in New Hampshire
prior to taking that job year and a half
ago I spent the last 15 years working on
cannabis policy I've been before this
committee many times advocating for
bills much like this and in fact I think
identical to this so This is actually a
handout the one pager I've given you
that I created four years ago when I was
working for the marijuana policy project
I updated it a couple weeks ago and got
my colleagues to sign off on it so it's
still their document but uh it has the
updated laws from
the rest of New England which at this
point the document is entirely filled in
it is now legal for
patients and adults 21 and older in
every New England State
except New Hampshire to grow limit
limited amounts of cannabis for their
own use the only exception is
Connecticut which will take effect on
July 1st of this year so that is in
statute but not yet in effect in in
Connecticut so when we talk about
cannabis legalization we're really
talking about two separate issues one is
legalizing possession getting people out
of the criminal justice system and the
other is regulation taxation consumer
protection
the first issue turns out to be much
simpler it's way easier to just stop
punishing people for possessing cannabis
and the other issue turns out is a
little bit complicated there are a
number of bills that have been filed I
think they're going to be a lot of
proposals to maybe amend them there are
a lot of policy choices that have to get
made
so tends to be more difficult to build
consensus around regulation policy
but I'm hoping that we will reach
consensus around this much simpler
Criminal Justice Reform
uh
I should point out Prime ATC is not
going to benefit from this in any way it
actually hurts our business but
much like with alcohol people can Brew
their own beer and if any alcohol
company came in here and said no there
should be felony penalties against home
brewing
I don't think we should like that very
much so as an ethical cannabis business
supporting the right of adults to grow
their own cannabis is very important to
me it's important for our leadership
team so
we're here to support it and would note
the benefit that would be tremendous for
patients who have been practically
begging for this for the last
12 years and have been rejected and come
very close and failed many times so it's
still a felony to grow your own cannabis
even if you're a registered patient in
New Hampshire this bill would change
that so would another bill but
you have to answer any questions thank
you
representative Newell
thank you for taking my question
um I'm curious that
in the between the difference with
therapeutic use being grown and and um
a a setting other than someone's home or
growing it in your backyard garden
perhaps right next to your tomatoes
um is there you know with other
substances there is a harm that if it is
unregulated and untested that many times
you will find something you know it'll
be more harmful right to get it in that
way can you speak to uh that
potentiality when it is grown in your
backyard perhaps right next to your face
absolutely thank you for question so
there are risks with cannabis
cultivation mold is a major one if it
becomes damp particularly after it's
harvested
these are issues both in the regulated
market and for home cultivators our hope
is that with home cultivation becoming
legal that we can do the sort of public
education that will allow people to
cultivate responsibly for themselves and
know as with their tomatoes that they're
not putting something harmful onto their
plants that will hurt them in the
regulated market there are unethical
companies and there have been documented
instances in other states where
Regulators have had to step in and say
hey here
you're adding stuff to your cannabis
you're we have independent lab testing
and you're failing it you know there are
in a regulated market there's a way to
deal with that in an unregulated Market
that currently serves New Hampshire
there is no product control so people
don't know what they're getting
if you're buying it from an unregulated
seller the the so-called illicit Market
uh you have no idea who who grew that
cannabis or what may have been added to
it uh and whether it's moldy or full of
heavy metals or pesticides so people who
buy from the atcs know that the products
are independently lab tested and labeled
according to what's actually in them
most people want that regulated market
patients and adult consumers but as with
alcohol for people who feel strongly
and have trouble frankly affording the
regulated products sometimes it's it's a
cost-effective option and most
importantly it's one that should not be
criminalized
and I follow up on that
thank you I I think I'm sorry because I
didn't frame the question very well I
should break these things down but it
comes out better my question is I think
what you're talking about is
um you know mold and things like that
these are things that would happen with
you know any plant when you're growing
it at home my question is to the level
of potency you know so if you're growing
it in your backyard is it suddenly going
to be ridiculously more potent than you
get it at uh you know in a therapeutic
setting or would it be you know do you
understand I'm sorry I'm not I'm not
saying it right but do you understand
the question and it's hard to hear and
hear so part of it is probably my years
either being full of lacks or fat
Acoustics but I I think I I understand
certainly from a patient perspective and
from adult consumer perspective being
able to know the potency of the Cannabis
you're consuming is important
think about alcohol if you walk into a
brewery and you don't know whether that
liquid in front of you is four percent
alcohol or nine percent alcohol that's
going to have a pretty important impact
on how many you're going to consume and
how you determine whether you're
impaired or not so that's a benefit to
the regulated market everything that's
sold in the ATC is everything that's
sold in regulated businesses anywhere is
labeled for the potency so that's a
downside of Home growth but if you're
growing at home first of all it's very
challenging to grow High potency
cannabis so most people are not going to
be able to achieve the high end of
potency but even if even if they can you
know they're gonna they're going to work
up to that and
if they're like most people they'll
realize the potency isn't really what
they're most interested in the people
who use cannabis are trying to feel
better
uh or less bad and the highest THC
product isn't necessary
people don't know how much is in their
home group either generally but they
have an idea and in my ideal World which
I think we can get to without too much
difficulty there will be independent
testing Labs available so if you want to
get your home care tested you
thank you
thank you for your testimony
at this time the chair recognizes Paul
Toomey
thank you Mr chair my name is Paul
Toomey I'm from Chichester
um I'm
the former House Council and it's really
an honor to be back here I've spent my
almost my entire professional life
litigating against governmental entities
and I must say the only one I really
love is New Hampshire House of
Representatives so it's really an honor
to be here
um you know I enjoyed being House
Council I was also a member of the 2017
commission that studied the question of
the legalization of marijuana and at
that time I was one of two members that
were charged with reviewing all the
scientific and medical data and then
reporting to the committee
that that reports available and if any
of you have an interest that I urge you
to take a look at some of the studies
that were referenced in the back
sections of it because it'll answer a
lot of questions that people bring up
about traffic safety and health and
things like that
um I was also
for 40 years of criminal defense lawyer
as I said when I was a public defender
for 10 of those years first in
Manchester whereas I was the office
manager of the Hillsborough County
Public Defender's office and then I
became the litigation director
for the entire State program
I presented and submitted written
testimony and I'm not going to go over
everything I said in there just like to
add a few things
I think the most the reason I'm here
really is because it's in my life
representing poor kids I was a poor kid
myself I grew up on welfare my friends
were all poor working class kids and I
know what these laws do to people like
that what they do is they steal their
future they make it so that even if kids
don't go to jail for it it's really
difficult to get a job it's really
difficult to get housing that's also
True by the way for veterans I
represented a lot of veterans who have
had problems getting you know being
afraid they were going to get thrown out
of their VA services or or subsidized
Federal housing because of simple
marijuana possession charges and that's
a population you should keep in mind
when poor kid when you go to court for
the last 30 years when he first was a
lawyer if you got busted with body you
risked actually going to jail again you
know having doing some serious time
sometimes up to 12 months after about
to say this
mid 80s that just sort of stopped for
the last 20 years I have never seen
a person
plead guilty or get convicted of
possession of marijuana or walked into
court with a lawyer I've seen hundreds
of people get convicted who went to the
arraignments without lawyers and knew
they couldn't afford a lawyer and knew
that if they asked for the state to
appoint a lawyer it was going to cost
them 300 600 and if they couldn't come
up with that they were going to end up
in jail
well those kids are the ones who plead
guilty nowadays the possession of
marijuana those are the kids who get
driven out of the workforce and when you
get driven out of the workforce in this
country you go to the crime Force I mean
it's just that simple people have to
survive and they're going to find a way
to survive and if you make it so that
somebody can't earn an honest living
they'll earn a dishonest living
we don't need that we need people
working
go to any store or any business in this
state you'll see they're just dying for
people to work but most of them won't
take a chance on hiring somebody with a
drug record so we just have to stop that
Madness it doesn't do anything it
doesn't change any Behavior anybody can
get marijuana anytime they want they can
either buy it on the street from a full
service drug deal who's going to give
them access to heroin and cocaine and
Fentanyl and anything else they want or
they can go to Massachusetts Maine
Vermont but nobody probably goes to
Canada it's a little too much but you
can go in any direction from New
Hampshire and get marijuana if you want
so you're not changing anybody's
Behavior what you're doing is driving it
underground I've heard some people say
that um well
that the drug deals will just undercut
the price and it doesn't matter that
happens if you get greedy and over you
know put the taxes Sky High but if you
make it sort of the way we deal with
alcohol and that there aren't either
make it a free thing where people do it
themselves or make it cheap enough that
won't happen you don't ever see people
selling alcohol in the street corners at
least I haven't seen it for a long time
um
there are several bills in before the
legislature with commercial models and I
am a member of a coalition
with a ACLU and AFP and
marijuana policy project that helped
draft
639 the majority leaders Bill and that's
bill I support but I think it's
critically important to have this
alternative available because there's a
lot of disagreement about the best way
to go forward with a commercial system
and none of those bills may pass but we
have to stop the madness we have to stop
you know just criminalizing poor kids
and keeping them you know basically
stealing their future so I guess I what
I would ask you to do is I think this is
a very important bill I ask you to pass
it so that there's an alternative if all
those other bills fail at least we can
stop harming people
hypocrite he said 2 500 years ago first
Do no harm and we need to stop doing
harm we've had a model
60 years of treating health problems
with with police resources it hasn't
worked at all the problems gotten worse
and worse and worse we have the worst
drug problem in the world and we have
the most stringent drug laws in the
world they just don't do it if you want
it there are health problems associated
with any substance
but we need to
stop trying to treat them with cages and
start trying to cheat them through our
health system and I don't have anything
else thank you very much for listening
to me
representative selig
thank you Mr chair I actually have a
procedural question this is the second
mention we've had of HB 639 which my
understanding is what to the Commerce
Committee does that if it passes through
Commerce then come to us
that'll be a determination that'll be up
to the speaker I I really I don't know
at this point nor do I know why it went
there instead of here other than perhaps
Logistics
thank you I couldn't hear the question
but it was for me I have a question for
you though the study you referenced is
that available online
I'm sorry the study that you referenced
that you that you um
I think it's available on the um
House website I can I can send it the
link to you I think it's still on the
House website I'll check with our
committee researchers thank you very
much yeah just if I could just say one
other thing about that there's a nitzis
survey in there on traffic accidents and
it's really interesting it's kind of
counter-intuitive they end up saying
that people marijuana does things that
make people worse drivers you know
inattentive you know
but it also makes them drive slower
because they're paranoid so it's ended
up saying it's sort of a wash that
doesn't mean anybody should go up and
ever drive on any substance but it's
really it's interesting and it's
counterintuitive so it's a lot of slow
speed crashes yes
crashes any any other questions
thank you
and chair recognizes Dr Hannah
hello again
um obviously I'm in favor of HP 344 for
home cultivation I was I believe I was
the other scientific reviewer for the
commission for the study back then
um so and and the slow the speed uh
thing was pretty funny too because I we
talked to some Law Enforcement Officers
like if someone can you tell what
someone's using during uh you know when
you pulled someone over like well
someone's speeding and swerving we know
they're drinking and if someone's doing
35 in the slow lane
and not even doing anything but going 35
miles an hour they're driving otherwise
safely like they're probably using just
cannabis so it was uh interesting uh
interesting study that we heard
um
so I I think this is a very important
bill even if any of the other cannabis
bills pass any of the full legalization
whether it's retail or State Stores or
private retailers Commerce or criminal
justice bill I think it's important that
this pass even is a standalone Bill not
just as a backup just in case but I
think it's it's important to allow a
home grow no different than home brewing
like we've heard of alcohol and of wine
and beer when I was on Commerce I did a
lot of Commerce Community a lot of
discussions about all those laws and
regulations there's no uh real oversight
of home brew so if anyone's worried
about home oversight of Home growth home
grow of cannabis it's probably going to
be no different than home brew of beer
and wine there's no Mass epidemic of uh
you know problems with home brew and
beer and wine even though you can have a
100 gallons of each if you want to do
100 gallons of wine 100 gallons of beer
if you're married you can have 200
gallons that's a lot of beer and wine
so you know this hasn't even come close
to those levels as far as usage levels I
think this is a drop in the bucket but
it's a great start
we also have the influence of other
states around us we heard testimony
already not being able to afford things
I'm pretty well off I can afford eggs
nowadays but not everyone can you know
uh am I going to run out and buy
chickens I've actually had this
discussion with my wife you know two
doctors talking about getting chickens
because it's it's
a little expensive we're pulling it off
but we've had the discussion
um you know we're not growing tomatoes
yet it's not that different we do have
an herb garden on our countertop though
where we grow oregano and basil but
we're getting little plants I've
actually killed a cactus before so this
bill would not help me one bit if I
decided to grow anything at home
um there are also uh looking at the uh
the influences of a home grow for not
just choice and uh also people that
aren't able to afford going out or
driving putting five dollars worth of
gas in your car and driving to another
state
um you know it also gives someone the
option of not you know supporting big
businesses that they don't want to
support they want to support you know if
since we don't even have Mom and Pops
they don't have to go support big
business and currently even if someone's
buying on the illicit Market they're
supporting big business the cartels
everyone talks about they don't want big
cannabis to come to New Hampshire it's
here it's run by cartels and criminals
so it already exists we want to make it
safer
um are people going to be poisoned by
this at home they're less likely I mean
very people who use pesticides at home
when they're growing little plants and
Gardens they're also the mental and
physical health benefits of gardening
there's there's many studies out there I
don't have them offhand but I'm sure you
can quickly Google some of the benefits
of gardening for reducing anxiety stress
and the visible benefits um
it's it's definitely something to
consider this is only for adults
children are not going to be doing this
I'm not worried about my 16 year old son
doing this but first of all it'll be
illegal anyway because this is only for
adults and he can't even clean his room
so I'm not worried about him starting
the garden
um
and as far as the legality like we've
heard it's everywhere nobody really has
a problem of getting it this is just an
option for people who would like to do
it and it is a hobby for some people no
one's going to be selling it it's not
allowed to be sold they can give away a
small amount so it's not even like the
person like I was thinking if I get too
many eggs when we get those chickens I
can make a few bucks selling it selling
them to offset the cost of my new Hen
House and feed you can't even do that
with this bill you you're not going to
make money it's not going to support a
small another business if someone does
it they'd be breaking the current law
anyway so it doesn't make any difference
and the amounts are so small anyway that
you're not going to have a thriving
business with a few little plants that
you can barely get going
so
um and and the last Point as far as the
pervasiveness of cannabis in the state
we know it's easy to get I mean it's
been used and sold within about 50 feet
of where I'm standing
at least once that I know of and I think
it's been reported in the paper too so
this is not a problem that is outside
these doors this is a problem that has
been inside this building and this is
not going to make the problem worse this
is not going to be something that's
going to really affect it much more than
a few people that can't afford to go out
or just have a hobby they'd like to to
enjoy and maybe have a little safer
product that isn't contaminated with
pesticides or whatever else the cartels
are using nowadays
I'd be happy to take any questions
no thank you I have a few first of all
on chickens are mean I have them I would
not recommend them
um I'm sorry chickens are mean I have
some I would I would not recommend
actually
um so from a launch law enforcement
perspective you paint a very bucolic
picture of you know the family having a
little plant and it's nice they're
talking to it but from a law enforcement
perspective if we were to legalize
personal growth
how from a law and Sport law enforcement
the way that they at least they used to
be able to detect growth that was
illegal in a home is one you'd look at
it from a thermal camera and it would
glow in New England in the middle of
winter if you have a grow going
um you pull the electric bills because
those lights take a lot of energy of
course now they're LED too so that went
green as well
um but how is it law enforcement officer
to determine who's running an illegal
grow operation in their basement versus
the the hobbyist well the the higher
amounts would still be illegal I'm sure
they're going to employ the same methods
they're currently using so nothing would
change there except they might show up
and be disappointed that it's only a hot
tub bed maybe a steam room and three
plants so there may be some
disappointment for not having some of
the larger busts and that's the only
downside they're going to still do what
they're doing uh and and most of the you
know people I've talked to I definitely
there's officers out there we've heard
them that you know it's a horrible
problem we have to stop I've yet to hear
one uh talk about busting a big still
operational where people are making too
much beer and wine at home I mean it
might happen but it's not some thing we
have ever heard I've never heard in the
state
I believe that's more of a southern
problem
representative Bolden
thanks for taking my question as you are
a man maybe you could explain man things
um I have been witness to
um beer brewing
and a beer brewing legal beer brewing in
in New Hampshire and I observed that uh
costs to purchase the equipment were
shared between friends and there was
sharing of the final product is that
legal to your knowledge currently I
don't think there's any prohibition on
like the components of any of the things
for making this up I mean you know you
can make us make any of that stuff but
just stuff you can find just any store
you don't have to buy a separate thing
there are kids you can buy you can mail
order wine kits and beer kits uh when
during prohibition there were there were
actually you know you could buy you know
kits online and online back then but you
can buy kids through the serious catalog
wherever it was back then they can make
it home so
um I don't I've never done it uh as far
as beer and wine uh as someone who took
a lot of chemistry classes as an
undergrad I I was aware of how to make
certain things but I never really
shared flasks and speakers with
neighbors so
thank you for attention
um is there anyone else wishing to
testify on HP 344
and we give for the record my name is
Heather Marie Brown and I am in support
of homegirl for New Hampshire citizens I
think that this will serve just about
every citizen that wants to take part in
this including therapeutic cannabis
patients for me I know one of the
barriers of a patient to overcome is
access and affordability to their
cannabis while by allowing home grow
whether for adult use or medicinal
purposes
that gives me another option to cut down
on those costs and expenses to have the
access to what it is I would like
in my own personal opinion growing
cannabis is not any different to me than
growing tomatoes or cucumbers and I've
often found it humorous of you know what
a big deal we make about the subject but
nobody's outlawing tomatoes and
cucumbers and they present a lot of the
same issues with contamination mold and
things like that as well
um I do also think that
by allowing home grow you are taking
away
another piece of the puzzle when it
comes to criminal activity within the
state you are giving citizens another
option instead of going an illegal route
or jeopardizing by crossing state
borders
I think that this is a great start and
an excellent way to start showing that
we care about New Hampshire citizens
safety and that we actually want to make
an improvement in crime in regards to
cannabis in the state thank you
thank you for your testimony
is there anyone else wishing that test
upon HP 344
there'll be none I will hereby close the
public hearing on HB 344 and the
committee will be in recess for five
minutes
eventually
safety
their boosters
Jewish
boys
Gary Michael
s
is
so I remember you know
because that's what this is this is
oh yeah yeah
so she works for every time
foreign
in three o'clock and I'm gonna
open the public hearing on HB 328
and who's going to do this
is anyone here to introduce us
yes please
thank you Mr chairman for the record my
name is Jennifer representative Jennifer
Rhodes I represent Cheshire District 17.
Winchester Richmond Marlboro Swansea I'm
sorry no longer more girl Winchester
Richmond
Swansea Fitzwilliam and Troy
um the prime sponsor is not here for
House Bill 328 I'm just here to
make the introduction
the chair recommend recognize Dr Han
hit the like
uh thank you for for hearing me again uh
I'll I just want to talk about a couple
brief things about uh some of the
substances that it basically addresses
psychedelic substances which are
generally considered not addictive
um and
the main effect people get are you know
a visual sensation changes
um people do not get compulsive use they
don't feel like they have to use it they
don't get any withdrawal if they don't
use it the only negative effect of using
it over time is there can be a decreased
threshold you might have to take a
little more to get the same effect over
time
um
you know this is It's the substances
have been around LSD is one of the newer
substances on the more synthetic ones
but some of the other things like peyote
and mescaline have been around for for
Millennia have been used in spiritual uh
for Spiritual purposes uh recreational
purposes
um in fact uh the founder of Alcoholics
Anonymous Bill Wilson one of the
co-founders uh relied on it heavily and
use it as a tool uh considered a part of
a tool for the 12 Steps so before what
you heard me say about the history of
substance use treatment in this country
has predominantly been abstinence based
it wasn't always that way in the very
beginning one of the founders was a
strong proponent of psychedelic
substances like LST for a spiritual
awakening and his spiritual awakening
that he wrote about and founded a lot of
the 12 steps on was from an experience
he had uh under the influence of LSD he
even wrote to the Swift psychologist
Carl Young back in 61 about it talking
about the need for a spiritual awakening
for some uh what they call Die Hard
alcoholics at the time and it's not
something that they require I mean I
went to a for years it's not something
they gave out in meetings they don't do
that it's not something for everyone
even they that you know Dr Carl Young
and Bill Wilson from AAA didn't say it
was mandatory but it was just a tool
that was available
um I I did some you know I know that
it's not addictive so I was wondering
why it's even a schedule one it was just
a question I and I kind of knew this but
I forgot doing this for a while so I
looked it back up and I found um a
little pamphlet from the National Drug
Intelligence Center as a component of
the U.S Department of Justice and it
says little handout says is LSD legal
yes schedule one substance under
controlled substance act schedule on
drugs which include heroin MDMA and has
a uh they have a high potential for
abuse and serve no medical purposes
um
and then in the same pamphlet it says
that uh where is it it's not considered
in the same pamphlet a different section
it says it's not considered addictive an
addictive drug
and that it does not produce compulsive
drug-seeking Behavior as cocaine heroin
and methamphetamine however they can
develop resistance over time and need
more to get the same effects so it's
it's illegal because it's a schedule one
drug and has no medicinal value and it
causes compulsive use and the same
pamphlet for the government is telling
us it doesn't really do that
um they don't even have their story
straight this is not something that has
has been a Scourge or a problem in any
way people do use it now does does could
someone do something under the influence
of a psychedelic substance it might not
be safe absolutely uh but that doesn't
mean that it's a compulsive addictive uh
substance
um
so anyway that's really I'm happy to
answer questions on it and um
that's about it I know there's probably
not a lot of speakers for this bill so
I'll shut up now
there'll be none thank you for your
testimony
thank you
chair recognizes Derek janazewski
thank you I'm here to speak in favor of
this bill I wanted to give some
supportive testimony to the gentleman
who just just spoke I'm a member of an
Alcoholics Anonymous I have had some
Addiction in my background
and I see the terrible terrible
um
effects of that addiction not just
inside the rooms and inside the halls of
AAA but on the streets of Manchester
where I live it's everywhere it's uh
really a problem
however as the gentleman before me said
this is the LSD is what Bill Wilson
received his spiritual awakening on the
whole premise of Alcoholics Anonymous is
based on a spiritual awakening and a
spiritual experience
having connection with conscious contact
with the higher power is the only thing
that's going to relieve the symptoms of
alcoholism
so
um this is the foundation of the most
popular and most successful
recovery program in the world has ever
seen
this substance LSD and to speak to the
safety a normal a normal dosage is
between 50 and 150 micrograms now
there's never been a recorded death from
an overdose of LSD
and the guess at what an overdose would
look like would be 14
000 micrograms
okay
um that would be 14
000 micrograms about 1400 times in
Normal
amount
there's been zero overdose deaths ever
as a matter of fact there's been zero
deaths due to LSD ever
uh and uh it's been used since 1943.
there have been some uh other deaths
that have been that have been a result
of the behaviors but none from the drug
psilocybin
psilocybin according to the National
Library of Medicine says all the
Psychedelic drugs psilocybin is reported
to have the most favorable safety uh
profile the vast evidence-based data
that exists for psilocybin suggests that
psilocybin may be the most efficacious
psychedelic drug for treating mood and
anxiety disorders espinal National
Library medicine studied by the by the
U.S government and the diseases that it
treats according to the National Library
of Medicine again alcohol-dependence
stimulant dependence cocaine addiction
tobacco addiction nicotine addiction or
opiate addiction cannabis dependence
anxiety disorders such as PTSD
generalized anxiety disorder
obsessive-compulsive disorder Advanced
stage cancer-related anxiety
psychological distress associated with
existential crisis of terminal diseases
and adjustment disorder with anxiety
along with a whole Litany of other
mental health issues
this is a solution to the drug problem
not the drug problem
as far as psilocybin overdoses
the overdose would be
for 150 pound person would be 19
000 micrograms nineteen thousand that's
1900 times the normal amount just to put
it into perspective
that's over 60 pounds of fresh
psychedelic mushrooms that somebody
would have to consume you'd literally
have to choke to death
to die from psilocybin mushrooms
mescaline which is found in peyote a
practice that's utilized by Native
Americans and also another plant called
San Pedro
according to the National Library of
Medicine mescaline addiction
Independence are practically absent and
it is clear that most intoxications
appear to be mild and are unlikely to
produce life-threatening symptoms which
favors contemporary interest in the
therapeutic potential
these are in a different class of
drugs because they're a different class
of drugs
they're purposely put into a different
class of drugs they're psychedelics
they're not stimulants they're not uh
opiates
these are not destroying America there's
nobody going out like I said the last
time when I saw you guys on uh nobody's
going out to cut out a catalytic
converter to get more mushrooms
this is not a public safety issue as a
matter of fact this is a public health
issue
um
and from there I'll I'll pass the time
I recall many years ago reading that LSD
caused the loss of brain cells is there
any truth to that
there's absolutely no truth to that
um there was a lot of propaganda and I
won't go on and on about that there's a
lot of misinformation that has just been
carried forward
there'll be North questions thank you
for your testimony thank you
is there anyone else wishing to testify
on this film
seeing none I'll close the public
hearing on hb3
28 in the house will meet excuse me the
committee have been recess until 3 45.
thank you
facility
yeah yeah
thank you
yeah
that's true yes very true
no it's been four years
we have fine conversations
every single thing
I mean I took one at the right time and
I was like are you kidding me like
oh yeah I did
4.78 .
thank you
yeah we're just home
everything else
very small
continues
please
years ago
foreign
right
thank you
foreign
yourself
degrees
next
time
thing
is
foreign
amazing
inspired
feel like
again
it's just
foreign
Beach
ES
is
everything
seriously
foreign
thank you
is
whatever
foreign
it being 3 45 and I'm going to open the
public hearing on HP 470 and recognize
representative Gathering to introduce
the bill
thank you Mr chair
I am Linda gathright from Hillsborough
10 out of Nashua and I am introducing
the bill for representative David Muse
who could not be here today
and I will read his testimony that he
would have forgiven had he been here
While others will give testimony today
on full scope of the problem and related
efforts in harm reduction Community to
save lives I'd like to focus on what we
can achieve by passing hb70 470
the first thing the bill would do is
provide an essential update to New
Hampshire's controlled Drug Act
under our current Law Drug checking
equipment such as fentanyl test strips
is considered to be drug paraphernalia
and possession is illegal what hb470
would do is carve out an exception in
our Drug law for drug checking equipment
such as fentanyl fentanyl test strips it
does does this by specifically removing
products from the current definition of
drug paraphernalia that process prepare
test analyze package repackage store or
contain drugs
the bill also adds critical definition
for drug checking
drug checking equipment drug supplies
and Drug Packaging it also specifically
excludes drug checking equipment such as
fentanyl test fits from our definition
of drug paraphernalia
for the first time in New Hampshire drug
law the bills also defines the concept
of harm reduction
harm reduction strategies aim to reduce
the negative consequences of drug use
such as overdose deaths and the spread
of HIV and hepatitis rather than trying
to eliminate drug use altogether
by providing a way for users to test
their drugs safely drug checking
products like fentanyl test strips are
harm reduction strategy that can help to
reduce the negative consequences of drug
use
one argument against making it easier
for users to check their drugs for
safety is that it cuddles drug users and
only encourage them to use more drugs
but the reality is the alternative to
drug checking equipment is not knowing
and the very real risk of overdoses and
deaths that add to the burden of our
Health Care system and our law
enforcement Community every day
the bottom line is that it was your son
or daughter holding a bottle of mystery
pills sold to them on the street with no
real Assurance of what they actually
contain wouldn't you want them to be
able to perform a quick inexpensive test
that would let them know for sure
the bill will allow them to do that
legally with much less risk of fatal
consequences
please send HB 470 onto the Full House
with an octopath recommendation
and I have a citation
that was given by organization called
medicalexpress.com you guys can go there
and take a look at that but they talked
to the greater harm and the greater
deaths that were soaring with black
teens in the United States
thank you
the chair recognized Dr Anne
hello again uh last time I promised for
the day
um I'm in favor of House Bill 470 a
little background I was I I wrote a bill
to allow some service programs back when
I was here in 2015 I guess it was uh it
didn't pass became another bill later
and now we'll have syringe service
programs around the state uh which are
allowed to have uh fentanyl test strips
and things like that be used as a part
of a program but this would allow it
just in you know at a broader level and
they could be given out more freely
I think it's very important one thing we
have to understand about uh substance
use and we've we've I've discussed this
with lots of people and some of them
here is one of the most dangerous things
about drug use is not knowing what
they're taking
uh if you went to the state liquor store
and you bought you know well they don't
sell beer but if you bought a six pack
of beer and one out of six beers could
kill you you know that's a problem uh
knowing what was in every beer if one of
them was the bad one or more dangerous
that would be a good bit of information
to have
um and it's not just about uh you know
finding out whether something I spent or
not I don't tell people that are using
uh fentanyl to test every time they get
fentanyl just New Hampshire has very
little heroin if they're using heroin
they're really using fentanyl for the
most part there's almost almost none I
can't remember the last time we've had a
heroin only overdose they're either poly
substance use and most of them contain
Fentanyl so it's really important to to
test other substances whether it's
cocaine methamphetamines and and most
importantly if they're using uh pills
because the black market for uh
counterfeit pills is much
greater and it's increasing all the time
back in the day it was Percocets in the
street were about a dollar a milligram
now it's even more it's really hard to
get because we've cracked down so much
on over prescribing and that did drop
the overdose result overdose deaths that
resulted from prescription drug use but
every state that Institute in one of
those programs had a drop in that in
those deaths had a corresponding
increase in debts from other Street and
illicit drugs so where there's a will
there's a way they're going to find a
way to do this and right now one of the
more more and I wouldn't say genius but
the way they're doing it is is pressing
pills and making other substances so
it's really important to to know what's
what they're taking
um and and something that didn't even
occur to me until was pointed out by one
of your honest team members earlier is
uh
check your kids stuff at home if they've
got something you're not sure about you
can check it
and I've got to go because I've got to
go go through my son's room when I get
home so I'd really appreciate if you
pass this bill it's it's definitely a
life-saving bill no matter what you
think about it being enabling Behavior
or anything like that it's you know it's
enabling people to check to make sure
something is what it says it is and you
know we we want everything to be what it
says it is and this is one way we can
find out
representative Bolden
thank you for taking my question do you
know or could you speak to whether
repeated exposure to like increasingly
stronger doses like unexpectedly higher
potency of drugs might um play into
someone's level of addiction or their
experience in taking illicit drugs you
mean specifically like Fentanyl
I guess I'm saying like
instead of if one in every six beers
kills you if one in every six Bill beers
is vodka right and you're an alcoholic
how is that
how is your inability to manage
um the content of what you're consuming
how does that play into the experience
of addiction
I imagine it would make it worse I mean
I don't know the literature involved in
the strength of you know how it affects
it but I know that if you take more of
something you can develop tolerance for
certain substances alcohol uh opioids
especially and as we heard earlier with
psychedelic drugs but they won't kill
you
um so I think it's important to know
what you're taking no matter what it is
I mean I put seasonings on my food I'd
like to know that it's not the super
concentrated hot sauce my son bought at
the spice store in Boston last week
because that was not an exciting thing
to find out really need to know what
you're getting
and and one thing with these test strips
that we commonly use now just tell you
whether it has fentanyl or not and you
can get them for different substances
and that's a great thing to have for all
kinds of different drugs if you're
trying to test for things uh some places
in Europe and around the world have
actually had you know concerts or par or
big venues or they'll have a drug
checking station
and we know they're happening in there
and it's a safer I think it's a great
idea that way you can check and see what
you know people are doing they're not
going to get something that's going to
kill them the other thing is
um well all right any more questions
no
thank you sure thank you
chair calls Kate Frey
oh thank you very much good afternoon
members of the committee I know you've
had a long day so I'll be really brief
and I have written testimony my name is
Kate Bryan the vice president of
advocacy for new Futures uh here in New
Hampshire we're a non-profit nonpartisan
organization that works on health and
wellness policies in New Hampshire we
work extensively with policy makers
stakeholders and prevention Partners to
prevent and reduce alcohol drug problems
on our state but also we work very
closely with recovery and treatment
organizations as well as evidence-based
arm reduction programs
so as we all know we um the state
experienced um still in the throes a
somewhat of an opiate crisis epidemic it
really peaked in 2017 with 490 deaths
that year new Futures supported other
harm reduction strategies
um around that time including making
Narcan more widely available in the Good
Samaritan law because of these
strategies along with improvements made
across the continued care for substance
use disorders we've seen a reduction of
Overdose deaths from 2018 to 2021 while
other states have continued to see
increases in drug overdoses
the testing kit such as fentanyl strips
are one is an additional proven strategy
to save lives according to CDC
fps's retinol test strips are a low-cost
method of helping prevent drug overdoses
and reducing harm
however the way the law is written now
it would be considered drug
paraphernalia
so recent reports as we all know
indicate that Sentinel is routinely
mixed with other drugs and so hv470
would allow one more tool in the toolbox
as far as being able to test the drugs
out there for fentanyl while we
supported a similar Bill heard last week
we do prefer this bill because it's a
approach it's kind of a much more
comprehensive approach to
drug testing so we asked that the
committee recommend onto pass on HB 470
I have my testimony as well as a
um article from International Journal of
drug policy that I think you heard a lot
about that I gotta just bring you a copy
it has to do with the effectiveness of
fentanyl test strips
thank you for your testimony if you want
to pass that down we'll uh distribute it
chair calls Lauren McKinley
hi my name is Lauren McGinley I am the
executive director of the New Hampshire
harm reduction coalition
um you might have heard me speak last
week on the previous bill regarding
fentanyl chest strips and while that is
an excellent Bill specific to
self-testing drugs for the presence of
fentanyl or other contaminants the bill
that you're looking at now is slightly
different because it is a much more
comprehensive approach to
our state's ability to identify not just
fentanyl but contaminants that are
showing up in drugs right now that can
cause I believe more harm than what
fentanyl has caused us in the past
decade
the the scary thing with our drug Supply
right now in our state is that we don't
know what we should be most scared of we
have some ability to identify because
our neighboring states have been doing
Supply testing like this
for a considerable amount of time at
least 10 years in Massachusetts
as we work closely with Massachusetts
and the team at Brandeis University who
leads the testing in that state we find
ourselves at a loss for being for being
able to be at the same level they are
for identifying drug contaminants
um so
this bill is going to provide a safe
state for us to be able to start to
explore
detailed drug testing capabilities
driven by participants of people that
utilize harm reduction programs
so people that attend harm reduction
programs would be able to bring a small
sample of the supply that they wish
tested and we would be able to test it
and not say yes or no there's fentanyl
but say there is this much fentanyl
there is this much additional
contaminant there's this much thylazine
there is this much you need to be
cautious of these things and we'll be
able to see growing Trends in our state
of what drugs are coming in how they're
getting in and what we need to do about
it to keep people safe from Fatal
overdoses
if there are any questions go ahead yes
representative Newell
uh I was wondering well first of all
thank you for taking my question
I was wondering if you could talk a
little bit about
um did you say it's called dialazine
I've only read it I haven't pronounced
it yes okay um I think you know most of
us are familiar with fentanyl I think
probably all of us are very familiar
with fentanyl and the consequences of
that xylazine is a new one and I think
that kind of uh you know gives us an
opportunity to to understand what's
coming at us in uh different ways so if
you could talk a little bit about
xylazine and the effects of that the
impact of that and and uh
I'd be happy to thank you for the
question
um xylazine is a contaminant that we
know is in our drug Supply because we're
seeing evidence in it in the way people
are experiencing overdoses and the
wounds that they're experiencing after
utilizing a supply with xylazine in it
so xylazine is a large animal
tranquilizer it is not approved for
human consumption and not only is it not
reactive to naloxone or Narcan as we
sometimes know it
um it it is it's going to produce a much
heavier overdose effect or
respiratory effect it's also going to
produce some very serious wounds on the
person's body they resemble Burns and
that's going to increase the rate of
infected wounds in our state and on our
Hospital systems
you're correct we know a lot about
Fentanyl and we do know that fentanyl is
in our supply but again what's very
concerning is we don't know what's not
what's in our supply currently because
we don't have programming like this I
would have loved to have brought a drug
Supply in New Hampshire drug Supply
checking professional to come and speak
to you about it but we don't have the
infrastructure in our state to set up a
program to start to look at our drug
Supply and what exists within it
so we don't really know what to be most
scared of right now
if I may um you said that there are
several things that are popping up is
there any other thing that's popping up
right now in our drug Supply that you're
aware of yes there's um so I know that
Dr Nolte is going to submit some data
for you from
drugsdata.org so I won't give away her
surprise but anybody is able to go to
drugstata.org you would be able to look
at State not just States from all over
the U.S but from all over the world that
take part in these comprehensive testing
programs like we are proposing today New
Hampshire will not have data on there
there'll be four pieces of data from New
Hampshire and that's it only because
Massachusetts was so kind to test four
samples of our supply but every other
state around us is able to produce these
comprehensive detailed reports about
what is in their drug Supply immediately
representative wheeler thank you Mr
chairman so if we pass this legislation
New Hampshire will be able to do a
similar drug data set like this yeah so
New Hampshire would start to show up on
drugstata.org and start to compare
internationally with what other entities
are able to do to keep their citizens
safe
thank you thank you very much
chair calls Carrie Nolte
thank you so much um to the committee
for the opportunity to speak to you um I
think I'm coming at a good spot
um of for follow-up I did provide some
printed materials that should be
circulated
um so um and does everyone have that
I'll reference that great
um so I'm Carrie Nolte I'm a family
nurse practitioner in community health
and an associate professor of Nursing
and my work focuses on reducing drug
related harm I've been very involved
with the harm reduction Coalition and
other and also police agencies around
Harvard auction and working through this
this is really the next step and I think
it's really important that the committee
considers moving this forward soon
because we don't want to get further
behind I think we're all behind our
other states in allowing drug checking
um and so we know of and I know the
committee had shared information around
fentanyl test strips and Rapid test
strips I think one really key point to
understand is although there's lots of
talk of Fentanyl and
across the state fentanyl is truly
become our the drug Supply the illicit
drug Supply that we have so
um in the last I think it's been five
years there have been one or two
heroin-related deaths in the state they
are all coming up with fentanyl whether
they be with other things as well but we
go through these cycles of different
things changing and although strategies
like fentanyl test strips come three
years after Fentanyl and can make a dent
and help this is a program that's really
going to have us be on the Forefront of
understanding what's there
um so I know you just heard about
xylazine I'll try not to be repetitive
you heard about some of the effects of
that
um in this packet on the um third page
I've provided a clinical bulletin that
recently just came out
um in January from the Department of
Safety regarding xylazine and that in
overdose deaths cases they're seeing
positive results for xylazine on the
following page and I think this gets to
what Lauren was talking about and the
questions
um this is a printout from drugstata a
publicly available data set and I'm not
going to go through all 10 pages but I
think just seeing the bulk of it and how
many samples have xylazine in it from
Massachusetts in the last three months
is compelling in itself but I did want
to point out as we've talked about two
primary substances Fentanyl and xylazine
in these conversations what really is in
some of these samples so if you take
just the first five samples there you
also see that there's procaine which is
used in dental procedures for numbing
you see there's caffeine you'll see that
there's also
um
quentapine which is Seroquel it's used
for Sleep psychosis bipolar disorder all
sorts of things you'll also see quinine
which you may recall is a malarial drug
so the the sedative effects of
medications are being combined and cut
and all of that so although now we know
in New Hampshire we have Fentanyl and
xylazine we don't know about all these
other substances and we don't have the
opportunity if new harmful things even
more harmful things are coming into play
um what that will be unless we allow
comprehensive drug checking
um I will I'm happy to take any
questions but I think you've heard a lot
from everyone and they don't want to be
duplicative
representative Newman
yeah just to have a quick question I
mean I see here that it says the drug
paraphernalia should not be included in
drug checking equipment and I don't see
any other added language to this bill
so I'm a little bit confused about I
mean this just makes it not
it's um it's not illegal but then there
was some conversation about the data
would be better and the state could
start checking and whatever and I don't
see anything like that in the bill how
how is this bill connected to getting
better and more checking in in the state
of New Hampshire so my apologies my
hearing I'm still recovering from an ear
infection and I'll I think I heard your
question but please correct me if I'm if
I'm wrong
um So currently
um my understanding of the paraphernalia
laws are that it explicitly does not
allow transporting sampling analyzing
testing and so this bill is aimed at the
testers you know my self-interested in
helping to develop a drug checking
program if I'm transporting samples to
send to confirmatory testing to
drugstata.org that I'm not arrested for
possession or for paraphernalia for
having baggies and things like that
does that get at your question or please
follow up clarify
um yeah it really does so it would be
private people or private organizations
that would not be held criminally now
for doing the things that you just
mentioned and
I I was under the misimpression that it
was that the state would be doing this
so well thank you very much yeah so my
current understanding of state and
testing is that they only test samples
if they're going to be utilized in court
cases so for if it's a baggie for
possession they the state has to do an
analysis on that that data is not able
to come back in real time just
anecdotally I've heard that the weights
on that are three to six months and so
the point of this is this is rapid
informing strategies informing
information in therefore reducing
overdose overdoses because of that we
will still need to build a program this
doesn't have this is all based on you
know most likely Federal funding and
federal grants but right now that it
those are available to support this and
the team you've seen in support of this
would probably be the team to be
applying and building that
thank you thank you
representative Newell
thank you for taking my question
um I was just curious about
um you know especially because you're
associated with the University of New
Hampshire is this uh are these skills
being taught
um to the next generation of of nurses
and things like that as or is it
something that would be allowed by this
bill I'm just curious how that kind of
works out
I mean I just clarify would something
like drug checking be taught
be involved students health profession
students yeah I guess I guess uh maybe
maybe that was a silly question it's
maybe obviously if testing is the same
across the board Is this different than
testing anything else
I'm so sorry my hearing about if someone
can repeat the question
is Is this different than testing uh in
other situations where this would need
to be specifically taught to nursing
students
um I think I mean my ideal would be that
students would be involved and this is
an amazing opportunity and it pairs very
well with an increased involvement we
have of our students in recovery
Community organizations and other
strategies
um the training in order to become
competent on rapid drug checking
um you know is challenging but
definitely something that those students
who wanted to learn that or make that
part of their practice could absolutely
join in doing and I must repeat and I do
have it in my written testimony that My
Views represent my expertise and
knowledge in this and not necessarily
the University of New Hampshire but
thank you
thank you for your testimony thank you
the chair recognizes Captain Bill bright
from New Hampshire State Police
good afternoon yeah thank you for
hearing my testimony on what has been a
very long day I'll try and keep it brief
for all of you
um my name is Bill Wright with the New
Hampshire State Police
I previously testified in the uh the
other drug paraphernalia bill I believe
it was last week that bill was uh narrow
it was very narrow and it included
removing the words testing and analyzing
um I testified that I didn't see any
unintended consequences at the time
um the one thing that I would like to
present is information to all of you as
you're considering both of these bills
is that the testing and analyzing of
these drugs using uh you know whatever
kits are available or whatever could be
used by somebody who is uh trafficking
narcotics they could use they could use
these things to determine you know what
they're getting for products uh what the
potency is and things like that so I
just throw that out there as information
to all of you that it is a possibility
that it could be used for nefarious
purposes as well
um as far as the harm reduction
standpoint goes the state police myself
we are very sympathetic to that mission
and I and I understand the intent of
this bill and the other Bill to allow
for
um people who are going to use a
substance anyways to determine the
potential safety or potential harms we
understand that
um and
but I do have some concerns about this
bill specifically
um without it being narrowly
um
yeah without the narrowness of the other
bill I'll draw your attention to page
two uh line uh 18 and 19. the the
language that's being taken out of uh
the drug paraphernalia definition is for
processing preparing testing analyzing
packaging repackaging storing and
containing so I can foresee some
scenarios where uh
especially packaging equipment
repackaging storing storing equipment
containing equipment where if those
thing items are removed from this
definition we may limit some
investigators who are trying to do their
job in building probable cause for drug
investigations going forward so that
including that language I I believe will
limit investigators from from
outside of the scope of the intent of
the bill
um I also think that the bill
contradicts itself as in page three
lines 34 and 35. the definition for drug
checking equipment
and says drug checking equipment does
not include
the substance is being analyzed
or drug packaging or drug supplies where
if we're striking out the the wording
for packaging and supplies in the
previous part of the bill
now we're saying that the definition
does not include drug packaging and Drug
supplies so I think if there is a
contradiction there and again
you know from a law enforcement
standpoint any packaging equipment any
supplies that have to do with
um you know narcotics or drugs in
general that would be important to our
mission in investigating cases
and I and I also do Wonder as well about
uh the line where it says drug checking
equipment does not include the
substances being analyzed
if if it doesn't include the substances
being analyzed then the the
um as the previous speaker was talking
about there may be some issues there
with the ability to to test uh drugs
that people bring to them I also would
offer that I believe that our state
forensic lab could offer some statistics
to
um you know what is included in these in
these drugs already
and there is intelligence out there as
far as the trends uh of the substances
that are included in the drugs that end
up in our state
are those is that information
um publicly available so some of it is
law enforcement sensitive
um so I can't offer up you know
everything that that goes out but those
Trends are
um available I'm sure some of them are
available to the public most of what I
see may be law enforcement sensitive
would you see a problem if if
if these
agencies that are involved in harm
reduction were licensed to do that and
and in other words if all this stuff
wasn't made available to the general
public but specifically the agencies
that were involved in harm reduction
with the would that present so I think
I would just offer that it may be uh it
may be difficult to set up a a situation
where somebody can bring an illegal
product to
um to one of these facilities to get
tested that I I mean I can see that as a
difficult situation the the locations
that you know the the people uh coming
and things like that I just would see
that as a difficult
um a difficult situation I do think that
in the in the harm reduction Mission if
things if this was narrowed to to a
sense that hey we know that fentanyl
um is killing people
um Fentanyl
specifically put the language to include
fentanyl testing strips or whatever
um the substances are that we identify
as the most harmful rather than just
opening up it up to any testing or any
analyzing so that would be something
that we would take a look at if it was
if it was narrow and was specific to
maybe not even the
um the potency but to the presence of a
certain narcotic or substance
are you able to to address the um the
drug or the substance that that was
testified to that's popping up that's
causing these sores this horse
so I I have limited information about it
similar to uh what was already testified
to so I just know that it is uh present
it has made its way to New Hampshire
um it has been prevalent in uh Southern
States for quite a while and yes it is
uh some type of causing some sores or
flesh eating issues in in the people
that are coming across it
thank you
representative Newell
thank you for taking my question I'm
curious
you know in the beginning you had said
that I you were concerned about you know
these same testing and analyzing
equipment could be used for you know a
um cartels or things like that is that
something that you've come across
um and I and if so how common is that
yeah I mean it's I think that it
if you open it up you take a tool away
from from law enforcement in those
situations you're also you know as as
the testing equipment gets more advanced
um I mean it's just a tool that a that a
drug trafficker could use I just want to
offer that as information
um I haven't seen it um recently but I
just offer that up as as information as
a potential uh issue can I ask a
follow-up
I just really quick have you ever seen
it have they ever seen testing equipment
I mean have you ever had the situation
uh that you're concerned about and
finding cartels having testing and
analyzing equipment is that something
that you have come across typically
typically we are you know we we may have
arrested a a trafficker and it's
typically they have the the products
with them the equipment package
um and to distribute and it's usually a
large amount in small small packages the
testing equipment I have I mean I
haven't seen that I'm just offering it
up as that is one potential Pitfall of
the testing equipment thank you
yeah
is your understanding of the bill I know
that one of the things you might look
for
um is an abundance in a vehicle of for
example small glassing packages
would this allow that now as would that
no longer be used towards to build
probable cause among other items well I
think you know I mean packaging
equipment is very broad right um there
you know there is a lot of broad
language in the drug paraphernalia
definition and statute
those things on their own do not
constitute probable cause for a surge so
anytime that law enforcement is coming
across these things it's usually because
we have already established that there
are other things there so but that helps
build the probable cause for
um you know for a judge to say oh yeah
we do believe that there is is something
illegal there and you are allowed to
serve it so
it would just take a tool away so yeah
in and of themselves the the packaging
uh you know containers things like that
without the the presence of an illegal
substance
they're not illegal but when they're
used in conjunction with
um
the trafficking of Narcotics then then
they do become part of the probable
cause that we would use I'm concerned
not only the probable cause but making
your case if if you're if you're trying
to make the leap from possession
to possession intent or actual dealing
you have to have a certain amount and
also packaging material to indicate that
this is the intent was to distribute
these drugs by taking this away with
that limit your ability to make a case
of of you make a good point I believe
that they could yes okay okay thank you
okay
thank you for taking my question thank
you Mr Jared
um I was just wondering if there was
language changes that could be made to
this bill that would leave it more open
to testing for other substances Beyond
fentanyl that the police department
would find more amenable
so I think I mean that just a suggestion
would be to identify the substances that
we're most worried about you know
whether that's uh fentanyl heroin
um you know methamphetamine things like
that and you know like if you were very
specific about about those things we
would we would look at that at that
language
like xylazine xylazine okay yeah
yeah represent wheeler thank you Mr
chair I just want for clarification I
think you might have mentioned in
orientation but is the state police
taking a position on this or do they
generally take positions so I I opposed
this one I was neutral on on the last
one I opposed this one because of how
broad it is
um so that that's my position on this
bill specifically the way it's written
up
there'd be no questions thank you thank
you is there anywhere else wishing to
testify on this bill
every now I'm going to close the public
hearing on HP 470.
Representatives please stand by for a
caucus
except for Democrats
let's drive safely